wow eth great hello everybody around the
world it is the final day of
January that's right it's the
31st we have got our toes no our whole
foot in the ocean that is known as 2024
we are a month in yep yo I want to do a
soundtrack to your
feet okay I'm into that thank you uh
Will I Am today's episode is sponsored
by real quick Teddy fresh thank you so
much
up by the way EST we started this as
like a joke the established in
2017 because the company was very young
when we started doing that it was like
established one year ago whatever but
now it's
been six years what year is it that's so
it's like you know hey check us out
six years anyway go to Teddy fresh.com
check it out some of the cool hip
designs look how fun this shirt is I
like that look how fun this is I like
that I dare you to find a more fun shirt
anywhere in the world you can't and you
won't dare you thank you
ducky anyway go check oh yeah this bag I
love beaded
bag
check it out fill that bag up and
finally one I want to showcase is the
Charmed choker which I'm a huge fan of
the teddy fresh jewelry but there's this
and so so much more thank you thank you
um Brucey is about to turn
two wow my boy is about to turn 2 years
old what crazy is that huh yeah
February 2nd 222 2 too right right oh
that's cool hard to
forget uh pretty exciting though I'm
excited to we're plann the fun birthday
party and I think it's going to be
really fun and he's just the best he's
so cute so
sweet we're going to have a new baby
coming up here pretty soon Ela is like
she's like
pretty she carries it super well so
like it's easy to not think about it
that much but she's coming up man like 2
months less month and a half Jesus wow W
never less a month and a week she the
she do the first week of April baby once
wait that' be two that' be two months
yeah that' be two months yeah but damn
God damn
okay a month there's going to be a
Sunbeam bursting out of her a a true be
like oh it's sunny mhm the doctor's
going to be like ah like a solar flare
yeah the brightest baby in the
world what's in
there uh we have a crazy show here for
you guys besides the Austin MC broom
stuff which I mean everybody's loving
and having fun and being captivated by
uh there's tons of Austin MC Brom
updates but beyond that there's tons of
cavcav updates including the long
anticipated failure podcast this is my
Super Bowl dude and it doesn't
disappoint it doesn't disappoint let's
go his first guest was an
interesting choice what uh the guy's
name is
Neil Nigel Nigel Nigel sorry thank you
letho Lithgow pronounced and he he's bad
Lithgow
he's been in the news for Well here
here's a lawsuit that claims he openly
groped uh two contestants they claimed
during this filming of the Series in
2003 and then also Paula ABD sued him
claiming multiple instances of assault
Paula Abdul like a month ago yikes oh
this is recent news saying it happened
or she just no no it happened years ago
she filed lawsuit in December like like
it just happened Paula he was he was
according to Paula assaulting one of the
main judges of the show right so that's
an interesting choice for first guest he
has a he he gravitates towards sexual
predators I've noticed well there's the
Harvey Weinstein thing Accused by the
way Nigel's accused I don't know if he
did it or not but Harvey he you can see
him kissing him on the head and that man
is not just accused he's a where could I
see that photo if I wanted to see that
does Ryan Kavanaugh look like Harvey
wein oh thank you thank you just type
Ryan Kavanaugh and thank you for that
good question Dan uh you type it into
the browser you click the website which
is now uh the hosting is phenomenal oh
yeah we're clean wow pop Notch will'll
never crash again
99.9999 up time unbelievable yeah uh
speaking of just him gravitating to
accused uh sexual predators I mean here
he is lovingly kissing Harvey on the
head nasty that's
crazy ran cavana is a force of nature
wait yeah hold on go ahead I think the
other guy in that photo is the GU is is
that Nigel I think that's
Nigel oh my God wait I got to pull up a
picture of him I don't think that's him
no I see the resemblance Dan but let's
see I mean that would be phenomenal well
we could look up on Getty Images I mean
can I just say this again this this is a
joke I don't mean this seriously but the
rule of
Threes right right right right you know
hold on I'm going to find that image on
on Getty that being said everybody in
the I need to say clarify this there's
no known accusations against Ryan of
anything of that sort yeah he has not
been accused of he's been accused of a
lot of things but being but doing an
essay or something like that has not
been one of
them as far as I know
he did joke about wanting a relationship
with a 14-year-old Natalie Portman at
one point but that a joke super
inappropriate super that was well he
also harassed her in email but that
makes it a little related toal that yeah
here is the Getty image okay so we have
the we have the names okay so it's
Harvey Weinstein John fimer yeah there
you go does he have any
accusations I don't I not that I'm aware
of who's well well hold on let's find
out who is jel John fimer the CEO of
lion gate Li wow okay let's do John not
get another uh uh movie producer pissed
off at us oh [__] look at the top result
sexual misconduct accusations Rock
Lion's gate you better she said she told
the CEO John fedman for the first time
in 201 you open please don't just go off
of the go little blur it's not about him
it's about she's saying she told him
okay yeah she said she told the CEO John
uh felt fimr for the first time in
2016 that Levan had spanked and groped
her I never did is there any updates or
some [__] I need to read
no update don't read the headline
whatever you do I never did update
please do not rely on the headline of
this article
never did all right
anyways whoa so anyway Ryan is out there
and it's phenomenal I mean this guy's
out there really doing press he did
another podcast on this weird right-wing
conserva can I say conservatard or is
that insensitive that's probably
insensitive yeah yeah
mhm so I won't say that bro right we
love them we love the uh we've moved out
of the era of
tards love the um
mentally uh you don't have to say this
part what should what is neuro not
neurod Divergent uh we love the narod
Divergent we do love them we also love
the uh here let me type what's what's
the correct special ability way to refer
to you know I had this qu just to back
you up I had this question the other day
too yeah I want to be Play Bring It Off
no like Ser I did I just to back you up
so here it is Zach the use of
intellectual disability has replaced
mental retardation and the US federal
law since 2010 wait why is everybody
saying F hold on oh no more YouTube
conspiracy they're taking us down
lag sorry about that okay are we here
saying it's fixed refesh I know what
happened maybe we had a little we had a
blip did you we had a blip people by the
way shout out to cam the the thumbnail
today is awesome
fantastic it's very good it looks like a
lifetime original movie coaster so good
Austin's my favorite right now he really
is I so anyway I was saying uh we love
the intellectually
disabled we love them especially
Dan
what let's move on let's what else we
got to talk about today huh what the
[__] was that 10 minutes in episode what
was that I just think he's a loving guy
he probably loves everybody a lot just
more than everybody on I was laughing
cuz I was so out of turn Jesus Christ
yeah uh all right I mean Where Do We
Begin Jesus Christ today I feel disabled
shout out to Hydro Flask who are now my
BFFs I want I wonder if they want to
work together look at them they're
hitting the Stanley Cups where it hurts
lead they
ask for over a decade hydr flask has not
had lead in our cealing process in 2012
we pioneered a new process that sealed
our bottles without the use of
lead we aim for a higher standard yo
they came out and they like these
[__] have lead in their [__]
that was pretty slick
marketing that's the the Stanley Cup
Thing They you
know they flew to Great Heights but they
flew too high as the uh the mythology
goes and their wings were burned MH uh
and their wings turns out was made of
lead
so let's see how their their clever CEO
spins that one yeah mhm I'm sure he's
working on something so Hydro Flask and
they it's held the the temperature
better anyway so fat
dubs
uh shout out shout out to our sister
podcast uh H3 the H oh this is the H3
leader this is is this the same gu
though I think this is different this on
new guy wait they're still on that G I
thought it was the same guy but I see
wait it's another H3 podcast like a
third H3 podcast just dropped yeah
wasn't the other one uh this is the H3
leader the other one's the H3 podcast
wow
okay well they differentiate it a little
bit that's cool but what's funny about
this this video is called the H stre
leader podcast trailer and people were
seeing this on their recommended fans of
this show Watchers of this show YouTube
and all of its infinite wisdom is
sending this to
them and every comment is about the show
it got recommended to me that's and you
d right oh was it cam yeah I think it
cam yeah that's I mean what the [__]
YouTube come on I I can't get a
recommendation they're like no no no go
watch the H3 leader he's the real deal
no offense to this man I'm sure he's
lovely yeah uh it reads the comments
read need to get this man on the podcast
wow Lord have mercy on this man's CH
these other HD podcasts as well have
like kind of a a a high Council of
h3s we should have a do a Meetup I tried
to to reach out to that other one i'
impossible to find that's a shame like
they just got some whack ass Facebook
page and it's I don't know I tried
that's a shame wow I can't believe
YouTube like served you this beautiful
cross-section of H3 and nature that's
like very is so tailored to you yeah
it's nice that's true exactly what to do
that's true I'm get the H3 drama podcast
tomorrow and by the way all these
comments are 2 months old so this is
like has nothing to do with me at all I
can't wait for you to join the great Zig
Ziggler on the H3 podcast this is Mega
Alpha energy so I'll be tuning in every
episode of the a stre
podcast wait he replied to one of those
down there oh he did repli well he's got
to be confused as [__] he doesn't know
what the hell's going on here that's
what I I laugh at the fact he's just
sting like what the [__] here this one
says H3 leader ex Nathaniel Clansman the
crossover we didn't know we needed and
then he responded to that with a smiley
face very good
wait yeah what you're not that guy pal
trust me you're not that guy family and
he says Nope not trying to be that guy
just being me okay that's you're not
that guy pal trust me you're not that
guy cheers my dude love you he says
thanks my dude dude so let's see what
it's all about I want to give it I want
to give him a good give it a fair Shake
where our goal is to provide a
consistent drip of foundational give me
that drip brother I need that consistent
drip let me hit me dude hit me with it
boy love me some good old drip love me
some good old southern drip now I'm
going to upload it cuz I love the energy
practical Insight motivation and actions
to help us all grow in the critical area
of leadership oh okay John Maxwell makes
a bold statement that everything Rises
and falls on leadership is this one true
from a perspective I believe it is we
probably ought to spend regular time and
forward see one shot today I want to
introduce you to my hope for this
podcast there's a few cuts to share with
you the early Vision pretty good though
pretty good well actually you know do
you have a rainbow effect happening or
is I guess it's just GL think it's just
Sun
W it's beautiful it's it's Sunny's beam
dude it kind of dude it kind of looks
like the H3 TV
background m
I'm going to fast forward see if there's
a cut yeah I can't tell
it's podcast Journey from here coming up
right after this oh he's got a little
Stinger oh we got a hey wow all right
all right so anyway shout out the H3
leader welcome to the um the welcome to
the
orbit the H3 orbit where I'm the black
hole
and everyone else is just in my
Galaxy
it's my Galaxy we're all thirsting for
this guy in our chat what oh come on
guys no I mean listen he don't say it
about anything look wait why he kind of
dot dot dot hello the [__] phone
there's no offense to this guy cuz like
God bless him and you know he looks fit
and he is wearing a wedding ring gal so
chill he's taken you don't think he's
fire leader podcast our goal is to
provide a consistent drip a
foundational carries
himself a little bit he's an REI weekend
warrior for sure dude you know REI yeah
like the recreation store you know I see
some people effing again right now in
the chat our Internet's having issues
today it's us or is it
YouTube that's what I want to know uh
hard to
say or is it Ben Affleck nothing else on
our internet seems to be down or having
any problems as far as people are saying
it's good for me we're back I think it's
YouTube dude they've been [__] with
us yeah you saw that thing love sent
this morning right of the uh so open it
up I sent it to my guy you sent it to
your guy yeah cuz you guys know how I've
been complaining a lot about oh happy
birthday by the way to Lena oh happy
birthday or I don't know when's the
exact date but I know you girls you
girls celebrated it yesterday yeah they
surprised me it was so nice
that's nice the girlies went out they
did a little birthday
celebration with no dudes no no Bros
allowed I didn't even hear about this
well that's because why would you yeah
that's what I'm saying I only heard
about it cuz Ela left me with the kids a
guy's trip the other day and we were
getting clowned on and yet this is
different though it's like a birthday
outing hold the phone D had a birthday
and he's like boys
only little iffy it's a double standard
you know you know what yep true yep all
right I'm glad that you yep yeah all
right so and I love that if you want we
can get together again for my birthday
and everyone's invited in I'm so down
second surprise party yeah that we're
planning right now all together just for
you
D um okay here's the uh here's the chart
we were talking about so I've been
complaining Non-Stop about how our
viewership is jumping like
10,000 viewers up and down like it make
it's it's effed up so you can see that
uh reflected in our graph here this is
over like a two or three hour period and
then here's Dr disrespect who obviously
YouTube doesn't want to destroy and has
relatively smooth line there that's
bizarre you know my
guy so I don't know YouTube has it out
for us they're [__] with us it's
absolutely without a doubt the
truth and shame on that new CEO whoever
he
is he's not and by the way if you want
to reach out to me we can talk about it
CEO let's talk yeah he knows let's see
Austin Butler we talked about him doing
that he gets stuck in the Elvis accent
and I just thought it was so silly I'm
sorry and apparently two years later
he's still stuck in it that week off I'm
sorry
man uh Austin Butler's Elvis Presley
accent apparently still linger in his
voice two years later to get rid of it
he had to hire a dialect coach to phase
out his Tennessee
twang please oh stop
it I I listen I don't think I've ever
even seen him in a movie I haven't seen
any of his films so I say this in a
total vacuum he really annoys
me I haven't even seen the movie I just
seen like one interview and yeah he just
seems so full of himself yeah he's a
[__] douche that's annoying bro
anyway here he is
and then I flew to London and then I at
that time it's covid so I'm quarantined
for 10 days I thought all right just
pour all this energy into learning about
World War II now right how would Elvis
fly play yeah exactly yeah I mean I had
a dialect coach just to help me not
sound like Elvis well it sounds like
he's he's a lot better now yeah he's
doing good I kind of like kind he's in
recovery back you guys hear that and you
don't hear Elvis yeah I just hear Elvis
no dude before it was way crazier Wanger
okay yes I still think he's like
lowering his voice there's Improvement
but there's character there yeah imagine
if I was like hey yeah guys it's me
Ethan hey everybody it's me talked like
this yeah howy everybody yeah imagine if
you sounded like that yeah yeah welcome
everybody to the H3 podcast I all I
thought about was Elvis for three years
and then I had that week off and then I
FL London and he seems okay he's he's
he's a lot better yeah he's trying if
you pull up the old clips man it is
really like does he not annoy are you in
now oh wow he's he's annoying me less
now that I see he's not doing it I
actually kind of like him now you like
you get a good positive impression of
him wow yeah that was that was the whole
that's annoying bro you know he's he's
in Dune so you will be seeing him all I
thought about like I don't know why they
always got to do this where they like
cast it's like oh they got to cast him
now and everything have you seen what he
looks like in Dune though he's like
unrecognizable he the white guy yeah one
of them you know what makes sense wait
oh he plays one of the he plays the
crazy son or the nephew the crazy nephew
yeah okay that's cool I like that yeah
that's sick Play Sting in the original
yeah as long as I don't know it's him I
think I'll like it I rewatched Dune
yesterday actually it really good it's
my favorite movie ever so favor movie
ever yeah I think so wow yeah I really
like it you should read the book then if
you love it that much do I don't and
then the second book and the third book
I listen to the audio book I've probably
never really read a whole book okay
never read a whole book like at all how
can you go through school school that's
impossible well like kind of have read
them but not really you were just in it
for to pass yeah you didn't pay
attention that much and it was used I
have too low attention span well Dune is
a if it's your favorite movie it might
be a good be a good entry point I've
been watch all these I watched all these
lore videos on YouTube on it so I've
been it's kind of like reading a book
you've done your reading what about an
audio book that's what yeah I should I
should I'll read I'll a lore that's a
lore YouTube video I've been wanting to
read I I buy audio books are good and
like I do it if I'm playing a video game
if I'm taking a walk if I'm exercising
when I'm driving you know what I mean
you can multitask I have a couple books
at home I bought them but they I read
two
pages you you know for a long time I
tried to do uh the Kindles or like
reading on like a tablet or whatever I
cannot do it I've gone back to just
buying paper books me too yeah it seems
so nice the idea of it it seems really
nice but then I just I immediately get
distracted I tried for years to like I
kept like going back to trying to like
all right I'm going to read this now now
I just go back to you know soft cover
books yeah the thing is reading is like
so timec consuming like as an activity
that it's I I haven't read a book since
it's the last book I read I reread 1984
like five when did I read that in a book
during some vacation we had I don't know
it's been years it's been
years everyone all the conservators were
like it's 1984 again I was like let me
read that book cuz I don't think they
know what they're talking about and sure
enough they they don't know what they're
talking about I do not know uh but
anyway Dune 2 should be good I'm excited
yeah yeah I mean look I started in Hol
when I was pretty young I think I was
running the studio when I was 25 so I
was arguably called the most powerful
you had nothing to do with I think I was
doing like 40 movies a year and 20 TV
shows Ry you didn't have you're not part
of this conversation I was around the
who who in Hollywood and um I was
working with like pretty much oh my God
bro your business went bankrupt Let It
Go stos um and so I was like you just
say created Marvel when I look around at
the people I had around that I felt like
were my friends that's an exaggeration
you don't know you don't know okay Ryan
move on man God damn you kind of think
annoying who gave this guy a podcast all
right Jesus Christ he is so
obnoxious uh a new gu drop I'm going to
blast through this because we have so
much to do new gu drop just something to
add to the soundboard give you guys a
little background
here it's doing this thing where it
doesn't load for no reason
yeah fighter and paramedic Dusty
gu born and raised in South Lake Tahoe
Dusty has been a firefighter and
paramedic with Taho Fire Protection
District for the past 5 years and he is
in his work uniform he is currently on
duty Dusty G Dy that's important uh
Laura back so we have we're collecting
the gues so I texted my friend cuz it
says he's raised in South Lake Tahoe and
my friend was
firefighter so I said do you know Dusty
gu he said oh yeah we sat next to each
other during my EMT class and I said is
he self Weare about the name and he's
like he's dealt with it his whole life
po a very good sense of humor about it
one of the nicest guys you'll ever meet
all right love that
Dusty hitting that old dusty trail he gu
Dusty go the thing that's so good is
that I mean d Dusty is really an
adjective so right it's like the whole
name is a package deal his parents the
dusty old gu they could have picked a
nicer adjective Gu Family Farm they
didn't think maybe King G yeah what did
gu was that not a thing like I don't
know 40 years ago
glowing you know I don't know let's see
like 40 years ago they may have not
known about the GU situation I found out
about gu from the first Jackass movie
same that's not 40 years ago yeah that's
probably the same
here all righty uh Dusty gu thank you
Dusty gu someone said maybe we can get
him to call in Ian I'd love to hear from
him I'd like to question him about his
life growing up as a GU I think that
could be
interesting all right I'll I'll write
that down thank
you well yeah but you can do more than
that cuz you know uh do you have a mess
you're well connected yeah I know some
he's with the GU is you're an honorary
gu
yourself Logan Paul is Logan Paul is not
okay um I'm pretty this isn't acting it
doesn't make any sense why would it be
they're doing a post fight
interview and he is not doing well here
let's take a
look uh do you have a message for
anybody else who wants to come after
your title yeah uh come get
it I need a second if you just give okay
so I feel bad in a sense but also it's
Logan Paul that's why I need you to grab
that Zack come get
it do you have a message for anybody
else who wants to come after your title
yeah uh come get
it I need a second has he talked about
what happened I mean I'm assuming he
just got a concussion or something come
get it yeah I'm looking for an update
now I'm not seeing anything has he been
in public since
this let me see he's so this was after a
WWE match yeah yes mhm it's
so it's so hard to know with anything
wrestling related I don't know it seems
genuine I wasn't questioning it until I
noticed that it said WWE at the bottom
well he's I he's wearing the a crane
[__] smashed him right in his head
that was Jeff not for anybody else who
wants to come after your title yeah uh
come get
it I mean he won he should be out there
flexing and like cele in yeah I mean I I
don't know I'm a mother freaking
blueberry come get it uh this article
from two days ago say there's no update
but he has tweeted that there's a new
episode of his podcast
so okay all right so he's he's not like
dead no okay or like permanent brain
damage that might actually improve his
situ like if he got permanent brain
damage that might actually like improve
him as a person he might be well more
frankly yeah you
know and as I said earlier we love the
intellectually uh disabled right
dan stop stop pushing I hope you get
betterly [__] [__] isolate yourself
isolate yourself Dan
come I'm kidding you know you know you
know I I kid who I love and that's
really what we do
here I have grown up with my man
speaking of WWE did you did you read any
of the uh Vince Wick man text messages
no I heard he's he's in trouble eh he's
in some serious trouble are they nasty
what what are they they're so nasty that
I didn't I I I uh that's why we haven't
talked about them that you literally
can't even read these can you paraphrase
one um one part he's talking
about he's talking about defecating on a
woman's head holy during a during a
three like he did it he's saying I did
do
this if he did or he was telling her
that he wants to do that to her there's
also something about a certain race of
people that he wants to it's it's like
racist [__] as crazy as you could
possibly imagine and so he resigned like
immediately afterwards he's done oh man
I didn't hear was a bit nasty yeah know
it's real bad someone said Ethan's
feeling a little old timey today yeah I
apolog
ologe apologize I'm just getting out of
my system here
folks
um wow I wonder how we can cover that
cuz that sounds really interesting so he
if you saw like it in detail it's like
if we read it out loud it would get us
yellowed for sure it's like he's the
longtime like owner CEO of the yeah he's
like the guy the guy that everybody
knows him without knowing him even if
you're not into wrestling cuz he's in a
million like gifts and memes and [__]
[__] and he's super I've always thought
he was super funny whenever he's out
there doing shtick I mean his like
character is funny yeah but he is he is
long been known to be an enormous piece
of [__] and there
are new layers that have been revealed
that go way deeper and who's alleging
this victims employee are bringing
lawsuits against him yeah
who and I wonder how they get all his
text do they just subpoena the phone
company I wonder how they do that uh
yeah uh probably yeah girl probably but
yeah it's in the law that's why this
came out is this lawsuit got filed and
in it there was included a bunch of
messages that were sent to her by him
and they're like oh he sent her that he
[__] on someone's head I think it was
that he wanted to [__] on her head wait
I thought he did I thought one of them
was that I forget there was a lot it I I
forget there's slightly different
context to a lot of them but they're all
like as nasty as you could possibly
imagine crazy oh man
yeah oh man Vin Vinnie how do you feel
about defecating on a on someone's head
does that sound like a good time or a
bad time do you it sound good it sounds
good he says okay when did this turn
into I love you when did this turn into
defecate on head world I have the great
luxury of
coming uh let's see here that's another
Vin that's currently in a sexual assault
lawsuit too yeah Vinnie boy everybody's
getting it man Cav Cav's first guest Cav
Cav's first guest Vince
McMahon guys dude ducky is
um ducky is harassing the [__] Alfredo
right now and I don't think Alfredo is
no that's how they he Alfredo's fine you
can tell when he's angry he's having fun
he he gets really loud and Ang biting
his tail constantly yeah I don't know
Alfredo he's a champ like he really puts
up with ducky was you Fredo but you see
they're
playing they're having fun yeah they're
having
fun
um Kanye West a little we got a little
clip here of him let's take a
look let's see here Kanye West grabs a
TMZ reporter's phone and then he offers
her double the salary to work for him
don't take that offer even for double
the salary trust
me based on what I heard about working
from him from like the Adidas
stuff this man is not someone you want
to for bi has free people are
saying she's TMZ she's TMZ how do you
feel like it's okay I'm a human being
all of this DM well are
you I mean look how a normal guy I mean
you're wearing rubber gloves and a mask
and yeah I mean now I don't know if
that's
true is this the new Vibe like uh rubber
cloves for handling like
barbecue what the [__]
uh I don't give a [__] what y'all got to
do what y'all going to do what y'all got
to say don't come at me with that [__]
ask me that you think walk up on me like
that would you think you a white woman
you could walk up on me like that how
are you supposed to have a conversation
with him it's so
weird okay and ask some dumb ass [__]
like that asking you my wife told her do
she get free will
are you crazy I didn't hear question
America this is America yeah so that's a
good point you to you for the devil oh
no not the devil you for T company I'm a
legend question public in America wait
was that an anti-semitic thing do you
work for the devil like referring to
like Harvey at
DMZ oh no I I think he's cool with TMZ
yeah they're like dogs yeah I think
they're cool I don't put anything past
this guy as one well we don't have to
speculate we know he does not like he is
very for many other reasons but in that
case I'm the the question that the
reporter asked is people want to know if
Bianca has her own free will some people
are saying that you're controlling her
okay that is a really dumb question
that's a horrible question I can see why
I pissed him off you know what I mean
like it's annoying does she have her own
free will what are you saying that she's
like sex trafficked that I'm like
holding her family host like what's some
sort of cult I think it's that I'm
trying to start some sort of like
Community out in Utah out Utah that I'm
trying to like gather all kinds of
extremists and people that are
ostracized by Society is that what
you're trying to say it's wild either
way but I'm doing all that but yeah she
has free making my own what are you
saying I'm making my own school to
indoctrinate the youth right I believe
the origin is because uh in the past he
had to approve Kim Kardashian's outfits
when she left the house supposedly and
because of some of the stuff his wife
has been wearing recently I guess some
people are talking about Kanye dressing
her obviously but she's down with it
yeah I mean like no one walks outside in
the outfit she W have you guys seen how
she dresses she she her top will be like
a
string that somehow is covering her
nipples like barely and that's her whole
outfit like a Le you know like the Ali G
leotard where it's just covers his junk
and it's like thong like that's how she
walks around every day outside in public
yeah of course it's
Kanye he wants to show God what uh I
know I'm not supposed to say that
Biden
yeah for come to me I'm a legend you
understand that I'm here to support
Charlie Wilson You Come ask me some
dumbass [__] about my wife that's my
wife you understand you was to ask me
[__] when I couldn't see my kids when I
could do you have questions do you have
it's giving Kelly when he starts crying
and like I I did this [__] man this my
life like you know what I mean just in
the the the reaction you understand you
wasn't asking [__] but I couldn't s's to
cry when I could do you have questions
do you have question I was my kids and
that I only get visitation and don't
have rights to where they go to school
you got questions for that are you part
of the system you understand word do you
understand what I'm saying you
understand I'm saying I hear you what do
you hear what do you hear about that got
your job to go up to every celebrity
asking some dumbass [__] about their
wife I mean she got a great shot out of
it looks like paid off it's good story
good yeah
inside no tell me was it wrong for you
to ask his poor pu say here's PR she's
like let's go inside please and then she
she just bails look how disappointed she
is how over no tell me was it wrong for
you to ask me about my wife some dumb
ass disrespectful [__] like that was
that wrong or
right I'm sorry it I just need my phone
no no answer the question he's still
holding her
phone oh that's crazy that's got to be a
crime it's yay it's not Kanye it's yay
I'm supposed to answer your questions
answer that question I got your phone
now they going to arrest you for taking
your phone arrest you for taking your
phone in I don't
you answered a question you asked me did
my wife have free will was that a
dumbass disrespectful question I mean
he's not wrong he's not wrong about that
it's a pertinent question I agree what
he's crazy dude dude he is a psychopath
he's [__] insane the [__] that he
does with his wife is seems really
abusive and [__] up seems like from
what I've seen and I don't follow it
closely but in public they seem like
obviously she's the way she's conducting
is nuts but it seems seems like they're
enjoying the experience together maybe I
don't know I don't know I'm just judging
I don't know either but I don't think
it's that stupid of a question to ask is
what I'm trying to say seem it's very
disres I don't know cuz like what are
you supposed to say like even for kany I
mean yeah that's true it is what are you
supposed to say she do she doesn't I
control her with my brain that's a good
point that would actually been a good
answer it's more of an accusation than a
question it's a rhetorical question like
what do you say to that there's no
answer to it I'm just stole that latest
phone ducky what are you chewing on but
yeah also so don't steal her phone yeah
like that's that is theft that's yeah
yeah don't do that ducky what you
chewing in his mouth still just what ah
I got you what is
[Music]
it piece of plastic do you not have
something to you
[Music]
here said a good
boy where's Alfredo here you go go
go there you go
enjoy be happy go with
God become as a grown ass
superhero he's a girl answer the
question what's your name what is your
first and last name Wai for to give her
a job offer what what are we doing I
just see my phone where is your no she
came to me and said does your wife have
free will to speak she work TMC right
it's not a legal isue who cares at this
point he's definitely in the
wrong it's it's yeah
yeah yeah how do you know me Miss I
don't know you what is her name how do
you know each other does he not know who
this is I don't think the cop knows wear
a mask I mean to be fair just some
weirdo with a mask on do we even know if
that is in fact
Conor I like to name I'm just a reporter
no you got just the reporter what's your
first and last name okay Melanie what
what's your address what you where is
the cop your what they paying
you
he's when's he offer a job right there
get her contact yes I will I will I will
wait what did he say hold on he said
I'll pay you double what they're paying
you get her info we'll get a contract
wo a now you smiling get a contract yes
I will I will I will or get her contact
yeah did okay I don't know what that
okay he's like I want to hire you he's
you're hired damn dude you got spunk kid
he's still yeah he's still a
little doesn't seem to have chilled out
that
much Christ is the king of all Kings but
some people just aren't chill and that's
okay we love the
unchill we love the unchill we love them
especially Ethan D chill I'm
chill you're
unchill I'm just chilling in Cedar and I
love that about
you uh blah blah blah George Carlin's
estate is suing the podcast okay haha
what's the deal Ethan I comments are all
like I'm not surprised that it was
written by people I'm surprised Ethan
thought it was funny okay who does who
does comedy for a living L who has the
credentials
here thank you
move past that
quickly uh Jason Nash got swatted on Tik
Tok I mean that sucks but no that sucks
there's no butt that
sucks that being
said the video was
removed uh okay he gets swatted I mean
there's really nothing to it he's on the
live and then the police come
in um that's really
horrible all right godl
we'
got so ab and preach made a response I
don't really want to get into it that
much with them because we have so much
other better stuff to talk about yeah
but
uh one funny detail of this so we talked
about them on
Monday yeah boy and uh we finished I
think we may even talked about them near
the end or the middle of the show so we
talked about them at around like maybe
4: 3: or 4 p.m. PST mhm now they're on
the East Coast cuz they're in Quebec
right so they're 3 hours ahead of
us so they went
home they posted this video the same day
as us they posted at like 11:00 p.m.
12:00 a.m. abouts 10m maybe 12:30 they
posted it at 12:30 a.m. so these
knuckleheads and they I don't know much
about them but apparently they both have
families so the these dudes with
families they they left their families
at [__] like 10
p.m. and then they they sped off to
their squeaky ass little
studio uh and and met up here to shoot
this and then posted it at 12:00
a.m. dude
these guys know how to capitalize on
some on some
te uh but that I thought that was kind
of funny that
detail dude wait for the morning you
know what I
mean but uh that was good the other
thing I want to address in it
is I felt like they were pretty
dishonest in the way they framed this a
lie I
don't I feel these guys are such morons
I don't know why the bridge is is is
mutilated by the way if anyone's
wondering the bridge is like fully laced
with TNT and there's a train coming and
I'm and you know what I mean it's like
World War II sabotage like that train is
going the [__]
down there's no train there's no Bridge
like him so I'm just going to go lie
about him assaulting me that is such an
insanely hurtful thing to say about any
woman ever it's a very humiliating
experience to go through something like
that and for for anyone to assume that
like someone claiming being a victim or
surviving something is like wanting to
boost so that's the edit that they made
originally that we were talking about
okay and um Olivia is being very
vulnerable she's being very emotional
and they are laughing at her I mean
there's no really way uh to other
interpret that and I mean they say well
we weren't we were laughing at Jordan
her because she lied so Amber herd
because she I don't know what
Jordan like I knew someone in like
Middle School named Jordan herd and like
it's still in my head somewhere it's
weird
um their their defense
is we were saying that some women do lie
so that's why we showed Amber herd but I
mean in the essence of it is they're
laughing at a girl who's being very
vulnerable and very emotional yeah and
they're laughing at her that I mean that
that's literally what's happening
there's really no other way to to cut it
and so the thrust of their video is
that some more [__] like the
original title was uh H3 crew accus us
of something evil like all right well it
was it was really mean I don't I don't
remember using the words evil I also
just like I don't even care if they knew
that I was assaulted or not like you're
making fun of a girl talking about what
it's like to come forward when girls are
raped like you were laughing at the
entire the entirety of what I was saying
that's [__] up and I still think that
that's [__] up even if you didn't know
it is [__] up yeah it is [__] up
sorry and not only that what they what
they did in their video
is not only did they not take any
accountability for this absolutely
malicious really nasty thing they did to
Olivia I feel like they
also heaped more blame on you yeah it's
like once you did know then that
something had happened to me why do you
have anything to speak on the worst
thing I've ever been through like why
are you posting a video on your Channel
about I don't know it just it makes me
feel icky and I'm entitled to kind of
think that they're the
worst oh Absolut I mean yeah of course
you are I mean here but I mean you can
see just what douches they are
he knows it's [__] up that's why
they're doing this right they know it's
[__] up yeah that's why it's funny
that's why it's so funny like why are we
acting like you guys aren't giant
[__] [__] for doing this like
that's the joke I mean look at you guys
you're on the
floor go is so incredibly wrong and inin
and informed that like you 1 million per
should not be making content about this
because you're teaching young men who
don't know anything about this and then
you're telling young women to not talk
to each other to not talk to anyone to
not tell anyone that something happened
because idiots like you and you know
what you sound like a feminist loser
okay so that was all their editing then
they do something really twisted in
their new video too that I want to
address though just going to interject I
do if you don't know who oliv is she's
the loser feminist researcher who spends
all her on Reddit boards and things
that's research okay sorry guys I'll
take it back mind you okay so
now this is from is this from their new
video No it's it's it's included in
their new video but it's from the
initial video so this is from their
initial video which they're doubling
down on so here's what he says that's
not me editing that they edited to the
soundboard and right in the middle of
what he's talking they started playing
their [__] that's [__] up that's
hilarious that's [__] up I was like
yeah you said tell her you
so I saw comments of people like oh when
I found out that um H3 played that that
was crazy we did not and like the the
accusation is if it's not like
intentionally misleading to lie about
what they did then it's just insanely
[__] I I would never do anything like
that thank you so much and I know that Z
that's I played the sound bite and and
by the way so I want to go back to that
cuz the sound bite you played was after
she was done talking and it was
perfectly timed and it was funny and it
was good so when he's like totally fine
so when he's like oh they played the
sound bite in the middle of her talking
the only one that you can reasonably
reference is the one that they did and
they tried to say oh we didn't even do
that what the [__] but I sad violin
which is what that song is called is not
even in my sound board women be trying
to ruin amateur sound it's an am there
you go nor would I want to demean or
diminish uh what you're saying thank you
yeah so they left that ambiguous which I
think is really [__] up they you know
what I mean just own what you did don't
be cowards and be like hey listen we
weren't trying to uh make fun of of
Olivia we were just saying like or M
they say okay they say they're making
fun of but they're like we our point was
just that Amber herd lied that's all
uh okay which all just all of it sucks
you suck just just accept that you're a
giant [__] uh douchebag at least
admit that you're a douchebag yeah all
they had to do is like
also I don't think that they're groeling
for my forgiveness but like all they had
to say was that was [__] up cuz it was
and it is and it always will be yeah
that was one of the that was the one
thing that I think of all the stuff that
they responded to us about was the most
[__] up one and this is the video they
erased in disgrace and I think a big
part of it was because of the way that
they patronized you they deleted it
quick yeah and um from their Masterpiece
called H3 loves black people these guys
have no [__]
limit
um uh so no bridge I said that you
missed it but the bridge is I stepped up
it's a bridge to a [__] Cliff it's
like a suicide bridge where you walk
down you think you're walking to
somewhere but you just fall off sure
yeah see AB been preach that's called
comedic timing and when did no land a
joke something you will never understand
oo well I don't know about that because
preach is a professional comedian
apparently allegedly he's he's an
alleged comedian yeah I don't want to
defame the good comedians of
Quebec he's
alleged men's lives it's CL it's just
what they do I'm going to go out of my
way to lie I don't like him so I'm just
going to go lie about him assaulting me
that is such an insane L hurtful thing
to say one more time just to drive the
point home woman ever it's a very
humiliating
experience like that and for for anyone
to assume that like
oliv something is them like wanting to
boost oh you you you're being naughty
being naughty they'll they try to deny
if they do respond that dude we didn't
we weren't doing that cuz we knew it was
[__] up we were just laughing cuz it's
funny what does this mean yeah this is
how you like let's not [__] be obtuse
about this yeah also they're watching
the raw footage they're not watching the
funny edit that they made they're just
watching me talk and then they paused it
and then they laughed I question that
because why else would he be
laughing must have edited beforeand you
think well because otherwise that's
psych like that's just what I assume I
don't you do editing and post absolutely
I've never done that where I edit
something well I mean not like it
doesn't make sense to me that he would
have edited it beforehand I agree but
then I don't know why preach is laughing
that's just how that's how I've always
read it and he's looking at Abba like
you did this [__] yeah maybe he said
something that they cut out maybe or
they're just giggling they're like she
oh my God this [__] you can hear the
playback from whatever they're watching
it on that slight second well they
definitely edited afterwards because the
it's the Amber herd is overlapped over
them right over their video footage if
you go back two seconds well that well
yeah if you go back well they he what I
think he showed him the video and then
he edited afterwards yeah that's I think
they showed this raw footage cuz this is
the same image that was over the other
one if that makes
sense uh this image is over late after
they recorded their reaction yeah he I'm
say that if he made the video beforehand
they watched it on a monitor and then he
put it in yeah and then edit it again I
I think the logic behind it makes sense
too because the way they talk about
Olivia being a loser researcher who
spends all her days on Reddit I mean
they just assume she's a girl some
leftist girl who's never experienced she
called her a feminist too was the cherry
on top just some girl really been
through anything have do you really care
about ESS you feminist loser no I'm
literally such a freak you are a freak
freak
but that's that's the thing even
following that line of thought and
saying that uh they didn't know anything
about Olivia going through anything they
never apologized in a general sense for
that being [__] up like you said they
double down that's all I wanted really
when I was like hey let's do this bridge
building thing frankly uh unfortunately
I had forgotten about a lot of this
stuff cuz it's been so long so much it's
so much [__] yeah there was a lot of
back and forth by the way uh preach or
he's preach right the one that pre is
the the uh the dancing sing
I think Olivia could give you some vocal
lessons
too we're coming after his voice now
he's his voice was okay n I'm just but
[__] it have you heard Olivia do um
toxic gossip train you should really you
could learn or after cuz if it was after
this is really crazy I mean it's crazy
either way you cut it
but
the only other option is he said
something super [__] up that they cut
out mhm and
then just look stupid
yeah go is so incredibly wrong and inin
and uninformed that like you 1 million
per should not be making content about
this because you're I'm sh this just to
see how they cover their about and then
you're telling young women to not talk
to each other to not talk to anyone to
not tell anyone that something happened
because idiots like you and you know
what you sound like a feminist loser
though I just G to interject I do if you
don't know
who she's the loser feminist researcher
who spends all her Day on Reddit boards
and thinks that's research okay sorry
guys I'll take it back yeah so do we
have that part
unedited or is it in this video even so
what wasn't working or anything yeah I
was trying to send a Discord sorry
internet 99.9 downtime baby we're back
we're we're running our own [__] fiber
optic cable in here that's right that
took months and cost a lot of money
back I mean to be
fair it is pretty good yeah it's pretty
reliable we've had it for years and it's
only come gone down a handful of times
yeah it is pretty so anyway I was
talking about I don't know where it
started to stutter out but I'm just I
want to show you guys the original to
show you how these cowards tried to
dodge
accountability so here is
uh when we played the sound bite such an
insanely hurtful thing to say about any
woman ever it's a very humiliating
experience to go through something like
that and for for anyone to assume that
like someone claiming being a victim or
surviving something is them like wanting
to boost their ego is so incredibly
wrong and inin and uninformed that like
you 1 million per should not be making
content about this because you're
teaching young men who don't know
anything about this and then you're
telling young women to not talk to each
other to not talk to anyone to not tell
anyone that something happened because
idiots like you old ass idiots like you
will say hey I'm an old ass idiot yeah
but you're not you're not mean and you
don't tell girls that they're
lying thank you yeah absolutely Vibe
check hey no no no young girls act like
that young girls act like that really
what's happening is that a young girl
isy yeah a 19-year-old was tried to get
picked up by a 35-year-old and you know
what you sound like a feminist loser
though if I just going to interject I do
you know who is she's the loser feminist
researcher who spends all her Day on
Reddit boards and thinks that's research
okay sorry guys I'll take it back yep
reel it back in that was what they said
when he's like oh they they put that
sound bite in the middle of the
monologue they did that he goes they did
that [__] no man so dumb what we did is
par for the course standard totally well
timed okay you guys are trying to dodge
the [__] accountability that you put
the Amber herd you put the sad music you
put the zooming in that was the problem
not us making fun of your dumbass sound
bite M
um the other thing they're saying
is I I think
they're there may have been a
misunderstanding
about their whole big uh issue with our
last video was that we claimed he was
laughing at your personal
experience and I think that may have
been a misunderstanding totally yeah I
still however don't really care like I
think that what they did
sucks yeah but the the point you were
making which they're unwilling to engage
with is that you you weren't saying that
women never lie you were saying you're
not which is what they say you said so
that you they could reduce it into
something that they can easily counter
instead of having an actual thought
original
thought um what you were saying is that
you guys are not equipped to have this
conversation to your 99% male audience
because I know there's no women watching
that [__] yeah uh and you are giving
them the wrong idea about accusers and
victims of essay and she's saying y'all
you know need to be careful about the
the messaging and the influence you guys
are putting out into the world she never
said uh nobody ever lies yeah so I mean
what the [__] yeah I was stating that
the conversation that they were choosing
to have in that video is
unproductive like to to platform more
stories about girls lying than to
platform actual like victims narrative
that's an unproductive way to move
forward in society I think that that's
ridiculous that's a nice way to put it
frankly thank you but yeah so like you
know and maybe just don't maybe just
don't do like silly edits over somebody
talking uh genuinely and emotionally
about essay thank you I agree with that
sentiment as well as a policy that's
probably a good one to follow you
know also statistic show that many women
have experienced sexual assault so just
be sensitive dude like from what I've
heard it's almost like half yeah yeah
the so do you really want to [__] do
that dude half it's so privileged to
think that a woman hasn't mhm hasn't
gone through something like that that's
why it's so annoying to me it's [__]
up
uh so anyway that was mine that was my
take on it their I thought their video
was lame that their video sucked he sent
me a tweet before they posted it being
like hey let's connect before I post our
response so we can talk about I said
okay so I messaged him and he sent me
some voice notes saying like just so you
know I just want to clarify that we
weren't making fun of Olivia's
experience uh we were just saying that
Amber herd lied so saying all women lie
isn't true which again she never said
and um
it's incredible how they distilled it
all down to that one point so they could
easily refute it which is something you
never said but anyway
um I listen to his voice notes and I was
just taking a moment to think about it
and before I could even respond they
posted this [__] video saying they
accused the crew accused us of something
evil at 12 a.m. [__] weirdos like why
did I I didn't expect you all to rush to
your office and quickly film and post it
at 12 a. I thought I had a moment to
think about
it 3 amm that whoa whoa whoa whoa they
uploaded that at 3:00 a.m. well they're
on East Coast time yeah what dude you
guys are that's see that's so pathetic
you guys left your family sleeping at
home so yall could come and post this at
3:00
a.m. that's
nuts little
bit they look cold too you can see
they're like all bundled up and their
and their new
one you know what I mean where is it I
mean I think that they're on East Coast
time right is Montreal East Coast or
they're in Quebec might be Central yeah
I think it is east coast we should make
sure though before we let's see Quebec
Time Zone Eastern Standard Time y yeah
dude you guys posted this at 3:00 a.m.
that's embarrassing you guys couldn't
wait till the morning you kind of like
self-reported by doing
that they're like we had the to get home
it was so evil what they accused us of I
had to get home and get up right away no
you didn't not at 12:00 a.m. 3:00
a.m. could have waited Their audience
isn't watching our show nobody's
watching like they were clamoring for a
response and nobody's watching YouTube
at 3 a.m. pretty much so right but
um I was hoping that I was expecting
that we'd have a chance to talk and I
thought maybe we could work it out
behind the scenes and we could come to
some kind of understanding but these
guys are such
uh content hungry clout demons that they
had to run home abandon their families
and post a video at 3:00
a.m. all bundled up in the Quebec Winter
cold uh staying very near to each other
to their body warmth could could warm
them I know that squeaky as Flo they
ain't got no heater in that [__]
burning the
witch they make it sound like it's just
like a Shack in the middle of the de the
forest or some
[__] but anyway uh that's my response I
think it sucks I think they're lame and
I think that bridge has fully imploded
man it's collapsed under its own weight
I feel very supported thank you guys
very much yeah sorry if it seemed I was
unsupportive last time I was forgetting
a lot and I didn't really understand
what was going on 100% understood uh you
know but there that is so I mean that's
pretty much it I think we said it
[Music]
all and shout out to again Chad just
said I'm watching YouTube at 3:00 a.m.
and the sad face okay you know
it's I love our 3:00 a.m. watch 3. right
now time zones I love our 3M Watchers
but the demographics of times people are
watching YouTube 3: a.m. is not not a
popular
one all right baby and squeak there they
are they're back to Babylon
squeak but you know like wanting to
build the bridge I mean listen it'd be
nice if everybody on YouTube and all
their communities didn't [__] hate my
guts that's my that's my feelings when
I'm like hey maybe we can you know like
uh mend some some bridges between
communities like that seems like a good
idea people go dude why is why are you
guys not getting new Subs it's well it's
because everybody on YouTube like you
guys have noticed if you're outside of
our community anywhere everyone's just
like hates me that maybe is a bit of an
exaggeration I don't give a [__] about
your feelings a lot of the good people
like you say what a lot of the great
people really like you the best yeah but
yeah I mean uh sorry for you
know not wanted the whole internet to
hate me I mean it'd be nice cuz I I feel
like there's a br there's there could be
an understanding between Their audience
and us I feel like there's there's
a there is a a bridge there I feel
there's people in their audience that
would watch I mean I see tons of com
comments Dan of people being like I W
which is part of the reason I want to
talk about it too was people go I watch
both of them really I watch both of you
guys and it sucks to see you guys
fighting [__] like that like I saw tons
of comments like that okay so I was like
okay well maybe there's something we can
do here but
no nah all right moving on we got so
much other better stuff to talk
about than
that thank
you oh here they are yeah look how cold
they are
dude preach has got like a damn
Siberian kind of fire Siberian uh
jacket yeah I mean what what's the
temperature at 3m. in Quebec you know I
think it's like uh 20° yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah defin go free
you got to dress warm for that one
guys crazy all right thank
you he goes there's a reason the whole
internet hates you yeah because you
[__] go on your videos and lie about
[__] that we
said for an easy dub because you know
what I mean the Ethan Hate Machine is a
it's a profitable business frankly it
does
well all right thank you so what should
we do we got the cavcav interview this
and we have so many he did not only his
failure podcast the premiere finally at
long last but he also did a podcast on a
or a interview on a on a website called
Patriot TV which is some really weird
hog true Patriots only 55 podcast it's a
hog website where they have like my
pillow ads and [__] beforehand and like
hell gold for cash and all this kind of
stuffff you
know so where do we want to go here or
or do you want to do um Austin mc mc uh
broomstick
McDonald's uh they're both good it's up
to you let's do an let's do a uh poll
because these are both super long
segments that I'm going to get sucked
into okay uh what do the
people want Austin McBroom update
where's the energy and bridge when it
comes to I listen that that situation is
way more complicated than my situation
with ab and preach uh Cav Cav uh failure
[Music]
podcast I will say about the uh
conspiracy podcast I love that in his
title card it says failure podcast but
it wasn't out yet at the time that was
pretty epic say again in the conspiracy
podcast he did his title card was said
Ryan Kavanagh valure podcast oh yeah
podcast like yeah a lower third but it
wasn't out right it's clearly Austin MC
Brun all right so let's do that then
that's good I'm glad Dan know that we'll
do the Cav Cav stuff afterwards I voted
for
cavcav cuz you know it tickles my but
Austin himself is great too you know I'm
not going to discriminate
there so go on the issue of a MC Brom we
had quite a debate on Monday
about
um whether or not he was essentially
lying about this whole
thing and uh the evidence is mounting up
cuz he's he's putting out stuff and he's
getting more and more
pathetic it's getting unbelievable it's
getting very
unbelievable here for example is a
screenshot of him in the shower to set
the tone for the day he posted this
photo I mean what the [__] that come on
what the hell also who took that the
phone is outside the glass who took the
photo that's from him and his body being
in the gym mhm so he's not naked no no
he's in the SAA oh okay he says always
push yourself to the Limit what is
happening there's a love a size
queen what nothing but this is a really
funny photo that's why I'm having an
issue with all this and with the caption
I like it it's working for me yeah so
there was a lot and it was kind of we
wanted a good timeline because we missed
stuff even before the RV so we went
through some videos and put together a
little
timeline it starts before the RV so
here's this all starts before what we
watched on Monday before the RV MH so
here he is Austin sends you now
apparently I got details that this is
Catherine's Bonnet that he's continuing
to wear in all his videos mhm which adds
an extra layer of sadness
yeah so Austin sends you a video when he
sick just got out of bed he got sick and
he was posting this [__] I got chills
and fever I've been sweating from head
to
toe what should I do y'all hopefully I
don't have the c
word should I go to the hospital just
like make sure no obvious what what I
what should I do y'all what should I do
I'm going try to take a cold
shower this man's not sick
don't that is not a sick man that is not
a sick man my friend man so here he has
a whole sick Arc before the RV here's
part
two here he is uh filming himself
dying guys we just made it back to the
house mother go inside get some rest
wait you're traveling around doing [__]
when you think you have
Co [__]
okay hold on he went to the doctor
that's hard to fake why would you that's
a lot High effort fake right yeah to go
wait at Urgent Care you know how long
you have to wait to see a doctor nobody
would want to spend their time doing
that nobody that's true I I think of
them everything in their life they find
a way to maximize content on it so he
has a doctor's appointment for whatever
it is already scheduled he's like all
right I'm yeah that's how I see it too
right I don't know about that spin that
a doctor's appointment beforehand yeah I
got a doctor's appointment tomorrow and
are you planning to do content there I
mean if I was in his position I would I
would maximize
it I want to go oh my tummy but if he's
trying to post a Snapchat cuz remember
he's times a day he's been a daily
vlogger for years too so he he he knows
the game he has not been a daily vlogger
for a long time he hasn't I don't think
so wait they've been infrequently
posting like well he has the he he knows
the game you know he's been he's been
that for a long time I feel like it's
his second nature oh [__] Chad's saying
you're being a do little Ethan by saying
he's not sick oh [__] true okay well I'm
not talking about a chronic illness so
I'm just saying I'm just saying
he this man does not have
Co I'm 100% sure that he is totally
fine that's my medical professional
[Music]
opinion he says when you're sick you
should start appreciation and you start
appreciating the things in your life so
much more I mean okay what things no
Ethan that's not how that works he
doesn't it's not like he has
lupus right got a fever yeah being a
baby um Austin reveals that he got a
house near Catherine we mentioned this
but we didn't watch it here it
is
all right y'all
so listen up listen listen listen listen
so I just pulled up to the house right
just got back from looking at all these
beautiful homes the homes you guys just
saw and don't get me wrong they're
beautiful absolutely gorgeous no I
didn't see those you guys saw them
apparently he was looking at $20 million
houses yeah they were yeah he was
pretending he was wasting a realtor's
time there's no [__] way listen I
know you've lived a successful life and
all this there's no way in hell that you
were able to afford a $20 million
mansion after a divorce by yourself
sorry no yeah I don't think so I don't
think so either but they're like 30
minutes away from my kids and that's
just way too far from me and so you guys
haven't seen the house yet but my first
choice the house that I really really
really want is like super close to my
kids and it's like golf cart distance
right not only that the house sits on
one one acre like the lot is one acre if
anybody knows how big a one acre is it's
massive so much room for activities and
so I've been praying for this home for
the last week that I move into it and
that this process can be so smooth for
my kids they can come back and forth to
my house to cather's house every day
like that's been my number one priority
is making sure my kids go through this
process as easy as possible and so I
just go back to the house and I get a
call from my agent he's like Austin
guess what I'm like what he's like you
got the house okay so I don't think he's
joking in this one I feel like in the
beginning it slowly morphs into him
playing it up mad cuz in this there's
there's nothing really there's no joke
here you know he wants to be nearest
kids there's a house in the
neighborhood I got it like I I think
straight forward here I think he's being
genuine uh In This Moment which makes me
think the divorce is still real but he's
playing up the pathetic angle
um and she she knows that she's in on it
too
probably
um but everyone's like started clouting
on him after this
because it's pretty weird for your ex to
setup shop a few doors down from you
although frankly I've heard of this
happening before I don't think it's that
uh crazy I mean I presume that she knew
and was okay with
it yeah you know and it would be nice
for the kids to have the parents walking
distance from each other that would be
good I think for them suppose so if if
both the parents were cool with it
right so uh Katherine shopping for
Austin's new house after she saw he had
nothing oh she's getting involved so
people are speculating that she's buying
stuff for him because he's using cuz he
uses her same products from Sephora
whatever products and people are saying
that he's using that as an excuse to get
back in the house so she's buying him a
set for
himself that's pretty funny okay I'm
here at Sephora bright and early because
I went to Austin's house to go check it
out on the inside today and I noticed
that he didn't have
anything hold on so I'm going to help
him out and get him all the things that
he uses hold on she went and checked his
house what house there's no
house
right which he didn't get he goes
something happened and it didn't happen
it's like
okay is she just being nice and
referring to the
RV house could be at that time they
thought they were getting that house
right yeah yeah I see but she said she
went there and Ted it I guess yeah she
probably went with him okay all right in
our bathroom or has been using an our
bathroom that is mine he steals my my
things so I'm going to help him out and
get him everything he needs to make his
life more
simpler and so that he feels like he has
his own thingies okay first things first
so anyway she's getting him products so
that he doesn't have to keep coming into
the house
okay very
good um Katherine responds to people
asking why she's getting him
stuff
okay why are you buying stuff for Austin
she said for his new home home because
he's the father of my children and his
home is also their home I'm also excited
for him and his new chapter and have
compassion and love for him why not not
everything in life has to end bad I'm
not angry bitter or spiteful all end an
an end is also a new beginning I mean
classy you know sure we'd all be better
off if uh divorced parents uh you know
didn't hate each other we'd all be
better off that's fair so we love that
uh Katherine earnestly answers a
question on Snapchat about whether or
not she has doubts about leaving
Austin the question is do you ever cry
about this situation or have doubts you
just look so strong and confident she
said cry yes crying is the best release
of expression when
purging wait purging I don't think she
mean purging emotions okay cuz purging
has a very specific no to expel okay
that makes sense I think okay no I know
what the word means I know what the word
means but like it's an ed in world it is
in that world that's what that means but
she just
means her feelings I've just never heard
anyone describe it like I'm purging my
feelings like sorry should I button that
well isn't that when people do iasa
isn't that like when they're all
throwing up Pur demons they say like
you're purging your emotions as well as
yeah that does involve throwing up
though so maybe that the vomb it's
literally purging that yeah maybe that's
where that met okay well whatever I I'm
not accusing her of anything I don't I
don't think she's doing anything I just
was struck by the by the verbiage
emotions are which are confusing to
understand even myself sometimes doubts
absolutely
not [__]
yeah um he actually did not get the
house here's the update on that one his
house I got something to share with you
guys you know regarding my living
situation it's been a little complicated
and there was like a minor minor
setback and I know in the end it'll be a
a big comeback they saw his credit
report they're like two lawsuits one
bankruptcy I'm not down with this you
know so it's a just a little minor
setback but you know everything is
working out and uh I'm getting ready to
show it to you guys and everyone's
really confused because he was
showing oh when did he say I mean I know
he said it but did he say it there no
longer had he just his minor set back I
got something to share with you guys you
know regarding my living situation it's
been a little complicated and there was
like a minor minor setback he did say
somewhere that he didn't get the house
but okay whatever now we're into the
RV uh the RV era now my theory on this I
think they got the vorest and I think in
this first chapter Austin is being his
he's being his pathetic self and then he
starts to see
like oh if I play this up this could be
good and also it Shields his ego when he
starts playing it up then he gets to be
like I did all this stuff on purpose and
he doesn't have to feel like a giant
loser CU he's he's playing it
up even though there's probably a lot of
truth behind the shtick so we're in the
RV Austin says the sprinklers are
getting his new house all wet let's take
a look never before seen RV era tck uh
snaps you [__] kidding me bro this
dude's property I'm on right now his
sprinkler just turned on and it's wet my
whole new house I just got this washed I
mean he's kid he goes the this dude's
property who I'm
on me bro this dude's property I'm on
right now just turned on and it's wet in
my whole new house I just got this
washed bro
I you know when one thing after another
just
keeps happening to you I feel like that
right now like this sh is so that's got
to be shtick it has to be yeah
okay I mean you got a little water on
your RV it's it's not a
setback you know Austin says he thinks
it's funny people thought he was
pretending to be sick so he wouldn't
have to move out let's take a look he's
aware he's self-aware uhoh don't know
this about me but like I'm on social
media but I'm not on social media let me
explain so true whenever I post on
social media with whatever it is I post
and I don't look at it like if you know
me or around me you'll know that I'll
create content and that's that like I
won't stay on my phone and look at my
phone and so on and so forth so Ray my
right hand as you guys know the other
day he he came to was like hey bro did
you see what someone said and lately
obviously people been saying all types
of [__] right what' you say what they
say the other day cuz I was sick they
got you on there when you posted about
when you were sick waking up from where
were you like in the shower and they got
you with your what was that like a hair
hair net and they got you looking
like you didn't want to get out the
house cuz you were sick so what they say
so like they're at this point they're
just taking anything you can be in the
car you can be here you this this might
even go viral yeah right it like looking
down bad like but what they say though
they said they said Austin doesn't want
to leave the house like he's
sick when I heard that that was the
funniest [__] ever because I could
really see someone doing that type of
[__] no but seriously I thought the
funniest thing cuz I can really see like
people doing that type of [__] like
imagine I was really acting like I was
sick so I didn't have to move out like
that sounds crazy bro this is not this
Is So Meta this become this is Artistic
at this point
this by the way have you ever seen
anyone on this Earth with that haircut
no just him is so truly it's that double
double hairline I mean give him give it
up for
originality mhm
right he got a hairline and he like he's
down to show it off it's almost like he
he doesn't want to commit to the the
curly hair because he he wants people
people to know that he still has a
hairline and so he does he wants to eat
his cake and have it too as as the
saying
goes very
good I don't know do you think he's
kidding in this one his assistant in on
it I'm so lost like when when you get to
the Final Chapter I am just by the third
final Arc of this I'm just don't know
what the [__] is going on anymore
yeah so let's keep going uh Austin is
pissed that the heater broke in his
RV cold nights right Snapchat fam giving
you guys a quick little update I'll be
honest I'm a little pissed off because
as you guys know I just got this RV and
the heater St working I've been living
in there for only a few
nights and I've been freezing my ass off
like my nipples are like candy
corns um never that I have people doing
work on it right now hopefully it won't
take long but I did reach out to one of
my boys to see can you if he's in the
street running AC from his camper that's
got to be gas powered right I mean it's
should be so [__] loud yeah like a
gas powered generator yeah yeah blasting
a heater unless he has like electrical
setup from the from Katherine's house
that'd be
crazy that'd be
crazy um
so now that the RV the heater doesn't
work at the RV so now we're moving on to
a new chapter this is never before seen
uh this is chapter 3 Post RV Austin MC
broom worth mentioning again as we
question the validity of all
this he did get busted really bad for
being in Catherine's bed like we can't
look past that y y where does that fit
in the timeline that would be
interesting to know AB
um let me Let me refresh it was on
Reddit let me that would be good that
would be good so here he is um thank you
he's staying now with a celebrity couple
he's friends with Daryl Dwayne
ddg
Grandberry Jr that's a long name Daryl
Dwayne Grandberry
Jr a Grandberry I want one of those I
like berries I never had a grand
berry and Haley
Bailey yeah fet you're Violet Violet hi
Bailey cool names so who are these
people I don't know anything about them
he's a little mermaid yeah she was the
new Little Mermaid okay and he's a
rapper and her boyfriend and they have a
newborn baby okay and they're they're
both successful so they're doing well I
assume she yeah she more so a bit than
him but yeah yeah that's like a A-list
role she got yeah for real and is she is
she still acting and stuff like getting
roles uh she does music she just gave
birth so I don't know if she's working
right
now so now Austin is going and staying
with
them uh who just had a newborn baby and
the stick that goes on here is hard to
believe but let's take a look all this
damn [__] got you little little gift too
for looking out for me bro oh [__] I got
this you got that for me cool congrats
on the Baby by the way too to you and
your lady man can't believe you a dad
now this there's no way he walked in and
didn't have these conversations with him
before
filming no way yeah you'll see all the
ads in this and you'll see why he's
stretching it out it is insane how many
ads he has God I'm so
jealous my day would be so interesting I
could do that that's what I'm saying you
hey guys what's up I'm live on the
podcast right now talking about Austin
McBroom okay okay if you had a doctor's
appointment You' you'd stretch it out if
if you were thinking in those terms
that's how I would but the prep the the
preposition that I'm doubting is the
amount of pre-planning that went into it
that's what I'm saying it wasn't
pre-plan like like this appointment that
I have tomorrow I scheduled like a month
ago so he didn't know but it just
happened to line up with his day so he
just he used it that I believe that I
that I believe that's what I'm kind of
thinking to he's just does does the best
of his situation yeah that that that I
believe
yeah that's crazy you know I've been to
this thing like three times you want to
double up
the right
now matching your first depit
100% [__] out they just they they do
gambling ads like that on Snapchat hell
yeah no wonder they're getting so much
money it's funny because they have to
have a bunch of kids on that app too I
from what I understand it's
predominantly kids it's illegal to to
promote kids in a lot of
countries well yeah and that's why
YouTube doesn't do it if you know if we
could get some gambling ads pre-rolls
that'd be great come on now I'll be like
I didn't run it I didn't you know the
cpm's probably great on that [__] you
know [__] yeah [__]
$100 let's get it y who is this guy I
don't know get but I want to do prize
pick I want to get it yeah let's call
this guy up what's he what's this
necklace
say Madden God
1144 Madden God can we research him I'm
curious well that's a video game no
Madden well the football gam right oh
he's a gamer okay we love that Gamers
unite oh
yeah by the way I'm kidding about I'm
being silly about all the working with
sponsors uh gambling sponsors and stuff
you guys okay thank you yeah I found a
video of him gaming I've never seen this
before he's playing Madden in front of a
full green screen and just standing
straight up as he's
playing he would do that he would do
that for the record I continuously
always turning down gambling sponsors
and they pay a
lot
so I need the max swen I need the max
swen that is the I've never
seen but I don't see it I'm in the wrong
Channel oh my God that is the funnest
[__] I've seen what the
[__] he looks like a four
four-year-old looks like he's trying to
pretend that he's on the field dude that
is so Mom said it's my turn on the Xbox
congratulations oh that's
funny how many people watching you
should move it so the people can't can
see okay wait do people watch this guy
uh this is a Facebook video has one
share um dude that's sick that he got
that that sponsor then that is so funny
that's a huge opportunity probably it
says he on Facebook he has 240k
followers it's not nothing he's just a
Facebook guy I love him I kind of love
him but only the one share you know he's
just doing his thing Facebook D okay
well I'm happy for him yeah we love him
first depit
100% yes you're probably have to skip
these unless you want to watch them all
the way through no okay go ahead
you know why I'm here need any advice I
got
you oh [__] this damn all right y'all
she all this
stuff Jesus Christ oh yeah so many ads
yeah at some point you should start the
whole video from the beginning and just
kind of skip through for a sec not right
now but just to see how many it's insane
wow wow oh
yeah oh good looking out I was hoping
would it be cool when you're we could
just be like hey AI can you just make a
super cut and count on the screen how
many ads there were in this cuz an hour
10 minutes I'm not going to ask cam to
do that well love show me a cool feature
in Adobe that will split up by the scene
changing and I mean that makes it a
little easier yeah yeah yeah I saw that
that's good that's great that's a cool
feature so much for social clips
you had a little matches
some so here is the the my God so they
set him up with a air
mattress in an empty guest room oh yeah
it's got a suitcase oh good looking out
I was hoping you had a little matches
something I ain't going to lie y'all
it's a nice room
the little
view see he got a basketball court out
here you know I'm going be hoping while
I'm here oh yeah I got to go down there
and Hope Oh yeah this A
vibe yep got a full
room so okay if we're saying this whole
thing is fake let's examine the room
okay because there's a lot going on here
he there's a ton of shoes there up
against the wall that that's some effort
sheesh
all this
[Music]
stuff oh good looking out oh wait no
okay they he hasn't been in here yet he
hasn't been in this room yet allegedly
yeah yeah okay so it's not his
shoes it's probably just like a guest
bedroom or something oh yeah this I
accidentally click the
ad oh yeah this A
vibe yep got a full room
batt he didn't go to
college he didn't go to college but he
does now apparently he's going back to
college that's another Arc I'm skipping
this
[__] he didn't go oh my
God oh my God what's
happening oh my God leave me alone
didn't go to college guy good all right
now I'm reminds me of when AB got robbed
and then he moved into his cousins and
had that air mattress out the same exact
air mattress yeah is it good uh it
popped oh so no yeah it wasn't that
great I slept on an air mattress one
time in my life and it was just horrible
like I don't know if there are good ones
or it was really bad yeah when when I
first got my apartment here in America I
slept on one for probably 3 weeks and it
kept in deflating you have to fill it up
every day no in the middle of the night
oh yeah I mean what the [__] what I
don't know that they there is even
possible to hold the air through the
night no so I had to like turn on the
thing half half awake so horrible oh
man life is hard they have better ones I
feel like now be well some of them we
got one for our nieces in Michigan and
it that one holds so the technology is
getting there we have we have ai
mattresses now they figure it
out y'all
um damn I don't know if I brought too
much I don't know see I'm going be
honest I don't know how long I'm going
to stay here um hopefully it ain't long
like I don't want to overstep my
boundary you know what I mean um but I
got to check in with he didn't go to
college dude leave me alone I never
asked for a raise go Toge I get
it no he worked hard do they do this
where they serve you the same ad over
and over and over again oh
God he didn't go to college so
interesting enough I made a new Snapchat
account to watch yeah that was my old
looks nice
cozy that was me after I got robbed yeah
but um I made a new Snapchat account to
watch his videos and I got no ads so
they must not feed them to you if it's a
new
account oh yeah well get you hooked oh
yeah okay wow that's interesting yeah hm
so they're like super targeted which
means they're more expensive and also on
that new account my first recommended
account was
Austin that you told me last time that's
incredible that is that's something God
RV and see um how long it's going to
take for them to fix the heater cuz I
would not want to be in there another
night with it being so free I don't
understand cuz you know how cold it is
right now in
La he's not wrong there it was super
cold there for a few days like a it was
so you
know maybe he's telling the truth
I can't have that again um so I'm going
check in with them in a little bit in
the meantime I'm about to show you guys
what didn't go to college I know man
never asked all right let me watch this
ad now I'm curious he never asked for a
raise you don't know who he's talking
about are you ready for the twist oh I
got skipped is that a political
ad kind of in a sense it is I'm checking
you haven't seen those no I don't know
what it is he's talking about Jesus
Christ my no way yep Jesus Christ is
running ads on Snapchat he didn't go to
college that's why it's so annoying
getting this footage because it's not
re-uploaded anywhere and it just plays
and the ad will continue to be longer if
you don't skip it so you can't even just
like leave your phone and record it
right Jesus was rich heg heus he.com he
gets us all of
us he he gets us.com
that is
one he gets us
St Jes he gets us
STC they could like capitalize the first
letter or
something it looks like a word I mean
it's got the vows in the right spot
get so Jesus didn't go to college yeah
he's born like what [__] 200 years
ago I mean what do you mean by that you
didn't go to UCLA yeah I know he didn't
get it
uhhuh I never asked for now in the name
of Jesus now in the name of Jesus also
what is this he never asked for a raise
like I'm sorry you're talking to
workingclass people you're like hey none
you losers should be asking for raises J
shut up don't ask for raises what is
that so do we know that is that
verifiable who's to say Jesus never got
a race he may have he's a carpenter
there's inflation back then didn't he
rise he did he he he rised he raised
he himself yeah he raised himself
brother so true I guess you can ask
yourself for a raise that doesn't
violate the rules of capitalism break
chair he
risked he never asked for a raise you
never complained to his boss about
nothing when his boss sent him nudes he
never said a word it's like whoa what
are you what are we doing here this
scene feels like a hidden agenda in this
ad okay we've seen enough baby yeah the
next part he plays some basketball oh he
wears his friend's Shoes by the way
that's gross he's wearing these
Balenciaga shoes that are like uh
elevated which aren't smart to play
basketball in all right so we saw the
air mattress here he is he goes in that
backyard to shoot hoops wasn't he a
semi-pro basketball player that was his
thing right I think college yeah college
so I mean that's a big deal playing in
college so here he is college good
question Jesus didn't go to college
idiot Jesus didn't play basketball the
biggest deal he did not play
basketball Jesus he gets
us Christ he gets us Jesus turned a
basketball into a loaf of bread dude mid
shot and it was a
three-pointer it's crazy he goes he
turned that airball into a three that's
right he goes Kobe and everybody in the
crowd saw it midair turned into a loaf
of bread all nothing but net boom from
half court that's insane dude the bread
bomb hollow bread
soft tasty uh-huh it's a it was a
beautiful occasion it us and when I ate
that hollow bread I just thought to
myself man this guy gets me come on
right now in the name of Jesus come on
right now in the name of Jesus it's one
of the great Miracles there's
Lazarus and then there's and then
there's the the half court bread
shot I'm telling y'all right now yeah
these shoes are absolutely ridiculous it
looks like he's wearing clogs and you
can hear them too they sound
heavy okay now okay now that was not
fake are you sure I watched it and I'll
show you this man twisted his ankle hard
you can see it he did not f take that I
let's see I have some other information
hold on oh before you well let's look at
the video with this
accusation okay let's
see
yeah dude no way that's a he rolled his
ankle how can you say
otherwise what he's pulling his it's
coming straight out of the back oh [__]
that does kind he's pulling his foot out
now I'll tell you why if you if you just
go look like a mistake but I don't think
his ankle rolls here okay he saw an
opportunity and he
ran it depends depends if you go back a
few minutes he sets this all up he he
picks out the shoes and like whoa I'm
like 2 feet taller than these and like
he's talking about the shoes and then
his dumb ass goes and plays
basketball and lifted shoes is mean he
knows how to tell a story listen to this
sound when he runs over in these
straight up clogs I'm just telling y'all
right
now I guess it depends where his foot
it's kind of hard to tell where his
foot's aiming I want to do a soundtrack
if it's aiming like forward
yeah could be a fake roll definitely
fake
fake he shows a close-up of his ankle
maybe we could roll it he didn't even
twist his ankle if he says he hurt his
ankle there that's yeah yeah [__] what
I've worn so like when I wear my high uh
heel
Crocs it's really [__] easy for those
things to go sideways so and in the I
believe I don't believe that this was
intentional yeah yeah this was a real I
think he just played it up again he's
just exaggerating everything that
happens to I have never known a dog that
has farts that smell like duckies like
it is
insane just violent
horrific
smell God
damn it's the pr in the stone new
lunchable dunkables those look good okay
yum damn big ass
shoes [__] balena some [__] bro
your shoes bro [__] messed up my
ankle damn
boy you got some ice or something mess
my ankle up bro [__] hold the phone he's
not talking to anyone is he oh he is
[__] think I got my [__] swollen
bro Turkish Airlines God damn it Turkish
Airlines oh yeah boy not ho uh there's
nothing going on never seen him look at
my [__] fool my [__] you got some ice or
something I mean yeah if he did roll it
it wouldn't be swollen already no didn't
full
[__] why is he D he caressed his leg
there like what the [__] look how he
look how he pulls it up look at
that pretty pretty was that a joke see
it's it's just playing it off being
weird
like look at
this what see them shoes of this court
damn all
right [__] God damn it you know he's
just bitching about his ankle
non-stop so M right now was getting
buckets
too oh this [__] hurt according to AB
and preach Austin editing this music by
the way
mhm so we so whatever we're say about
him it's his fault oh man I just got
done being sick now I hurt twisting my
damn in English oh my God bro all right
should I keep watching or move on um
Chad's saying that's the wrong
foot is that right or maybe because the
camera's flipped it looks different he's
not that dumb yeah I don't think it
seemed like the right foot to me hold on
let me think about
it well I see what they're saying cuz if
hold on
okay he rolled
his oh it's his right foot he rolled his
right foot M and when he's sitting down
he seems to be actually caressing his
left foot right that's what it looks
like that's his left foot am I missing
something unless he took it on selfie
cam is it something with the camera beam
yeah I don't know could it be flipped
well the text is flipped on shirt when
he goes is it shoes [__] see he's not
using that camera right
yeah he is caressing the wrong foot well
he could have taken this one with selfie
cam too the basketball so it could be
his left foot oh yeah he is you're right
yeah I guess it's inconclusive no it's
true Olivia yeah you yeah I think so
let's go look the text is backwards yeah
so then it is the right foot yeah okay
nice what do we do ab should I move on
you can move on cam sent uh further
analysis excellent thank you Cam let me
see what we
got this is actually from um Douglas
275 it's when uh Jesus straight [__]
stunted on the devil with an assist from
Austin MC
Brom wasn't college ball
though Divine it's God it's God
League he actually tore Satan's head off
threw it in the basket from half court
it turned into a [__] turned into a
fish a lot of y'all just love just to
like hold our ball sack you know what I
mean no
what we just love to hold our ball sack
hold our ball sack you know what I mean
um but yeah you can move on to the next
what's this art where what the [__] is
this I don't know it's a famous meme oh
it is yeah that's awesome have some
weird
painting well that's exactly what I was
imagining like it when it comes judgment
time it's not going to be the writers of
the Apocalypse it's not going to be
Hellfire it's going to be oneon-one
God verse
Satan half you know what I mean full
court first to 11
points blood boiling that's how the Our
Fate will be
decided thank you can't wait a lot of
y'all just love to just like hold our
ball SA
here he is being asked to turn down his
music because they have a newborn baby
who's trying to sleep yeah this Tik Tok
sums it up pretty well cuz kind of
belong this cannot oh she okay so who's
this I want to shout her out she going
to watch her video here I can see it
here it's
Becca day Becca day b e k a h d a y y y
we can put the link in the
description if we're going to you know
watch her
video all right go ahead Becca day we're
doing that you want me to find her and
put her in the description yeah okay
well I mean I don't I haven't watched
the video
but I do want to credit people
who's whose videos we're using I mean
she she went through the effort of
putting this all together be real life
it's getting worse by the moment so I
just want to like walk you through what
this interaction is and then we're going
to watch it I have no idea what is wrong
with Austin MC broom but basically he is
in hi Bailey and dtg's kitchen and he is
making himself Ramen and dgg comes walks
right by him and makes sure to say hey
make sure to keep it down the baby's
sleeping you know they brand new baby
fresh from the womb baby so what does
Austin do he walks around and turns on
music EDG is like bro what are you doing
and Austin MC broom is like oh my bad
but then cut to the next slide Austin
McBroom is talking about how the baby's
crying and you can hear hie and DG's
baby crying in the background of these
Snapchat I mean dude there's no way this
is real I've seen these ones and it's
like there's no
way but there's a baby a real baby
crying yeah and there is a real baby in
that house yes let's see this man is
living on top Ramen holy
[__] yum I love Top Ramen but yeah
what's wrong with that I mean that's
like the EP that's like the symbol of oh
yeah single life mhm doesn't get better
than that 99 Cents baby 99 Cents no
that's way overpaying oh for real they
like 39 cents well I don't know like
when I used to buy it in bulk in like
college and was like living off of it it
was like 20 cents per one of those that
is
suspicious 45 cents at Target oh
compleation thank Joe Brandon I have
grown up with me man yeah it's true 45
cents man Top Ramen [__] yeah all right
go ahead Austin so on for
me you want high medium low yeah I like
my
[__] why is he asking him how he wants
his flame does Austin is he not allowed
to touch the stove top light my [__]
isn't he sick he seems fine now I don't
know I don't know how much time passed
okay because like newborn babies you
need to be careful yeah the was before
the RV Arc right I I think that was I
mean wasn't the RV Arc only a few days
Snapchat only lasts 24 hours that's all
that matters he's a new
man it's a new cycle yeah by the way the
reminds me poor bruy he got Co a when he
was newborn it was such a [__]
nightmare dude we all had it it was the
worst
oh he's great though I love that that
he's
great
yeah felt so bad for him it's like God
damn the worst
[__] timing
[Music]
ever you got put water in it
first no shot he doesn't know how to
make ramen you got to put I think you
got to put water in it
first yeah you're what are you going to
fry it got to put water in boil it
Austin is 30 years old he's 30 years old
and he just had to be reminded to put
water in his to keep a little quiet CU
it B SLE all right I got you you heard
that got three key I'm went through this
whole
process he said he went through the
process of cooking Ramen three times no
he had no three
kids oh he has he said I have three kids
yeah he's been yeah he knows the deal
knows the deal but clearly he doesn't
yeah he wasn't taking care of
him well he might have been cuz this is
not real there's no
way I have to uh mute it here so he's
playing copyrighted music yeah okay and
give me just a touch of it for a second
so we can see how loud is
it it's pretty
loud
okay man how how long does it take you
cook ramen in like 1
minute
boiling uh it's going the music is
playing I don't know what's happening
you can start to hear the baby give me
some audio let's see my B he just told
you the baby's
sleeping the baby's crying
[Music]
cry why is he telling the world that
this baby is
crying how many days do you guys think
it okay he's like y the baby's crying no
way this is all phony baloney this whole
kitchen scene
yeah it's
obvious I still think his ass is divorce
though I really do
yeah I'm willing to go along on the on
the conspiracy up to a point of you know
him playing into playing all this up and
everything but she's definitely leaving
him I'm still what I think that like
she's ready to move on yeah she posted a
snap yesterday showing a bunch of uh
actually let me type it in chat I don't
know if I could say it bunch of adult
toys Katherine showed a bunch of dildos
vibrators yeah
yeah for real like she showed like
here's my Personal Collection no she was
like at a store and she's like oh I'm
just I'm just uh wanted to record this
to show somebody I forgot who she said
that this is a thing but it will fit my
favorite dildo
perfectly
um
okay so what she's shopping cuz she's
she's not what what's the
implication I mean everyone has eyes on
them in the divorce and she's posting
snaps of a bunch of dildos or a bunch of
vibrators I mean I I don't know exactly
married women use
vibrators yeah they don't usually post
uh them shopping for them no no no they
don't certainly a private a private or I
got a new strap strap on harness today
Senator please whoa there bucko I can't
wait to have your [__] in my mouth Mr
Kennedy Jesus Christ that is vulgar and
I began to slide into him from behind
Okay contain yourself
sir that's disgusting sh looks so
hot all right so uh how many days do you
guys think it will be before uh hi
Bailey kicks this man oh so she wrote
that yeah we can move on to the next
link it will be before hi Bailey kicks
this man to the curb or maybe the one
maybe both of
them
okay is there a consensus out in the
wild that this is all
fake like it's starting to turn that way
I mean certainly when we saw the
screenshot of him uh in the bed the
other day is when questions started to
really be raised but as we're about to
see it his behavior is becoming so
obviously shtick that it's impossible to
deny at this point
all right well let's
continue um we could go to CVS right
here moving on to a CVS Showdown I saw
now I caught this one this one was
pretty interesting uh he's shopping at
CVS and one of the cashiers recognizes
him and it turns into an altercation
actually if you can believe
that let's listen living in RV have a
bless what aren't you living in an AR
yeah I am bro you're talking under your
breath [__] that's crazy that's yeah I'm
living in RV is that a problem no I was
just wondering cuz like you be talking
some crazy stuff right now I was just
wondering oh yeah was talking cuz the
lady cut me yeah okay yeah I can't live
in RV no you can he's talking [__] about
me cuz I'm live in RV that's crazy
that's crazy and he's working at CVS
that is CRA that's [__] up that's
[__] up bye I'm living in an RV bye I
mean he seems
mad seems mad seems a little little mad
there but also is this not why does the
guy at CVS know who tin McBroom is what
do you mean he's famous people recognize
me at the grocery store aren't you the
guy who lives in an RV pretty funny I
mean it was exploded he could be a fan
of ours that that was my theory yeah
don't you live in RV guy if if you're in
the audience oh my God they could settle
it if he's like yeah that was a real
interaction then right could do
something right okay I saw people saying
he's not even at their cash register so
let's see if we can make an assessment
of if he's at the right spot perfect
thank you so much I
appreciate oh he got cut by this lady
he's at the front you can see all the
goodies there but this this whole lady
cutting him this is another one of those
situations where it's just probably a
lady in line he's like all right more
content for sure for
[Music]
sure she just cut
me she just cut me wait he's kind of
funny why is he kind of
funny maybe like he's still a scammer
and all that but cut you off in reality
it's not y all got scammed you off are
you thinking about bridges right now sir
he never said he never done me wrong
having dreams about arches he never
Bridges hey Austin never you know
crossed the line with me I will say he
gave me similar Vibes to other streamers
like where I watch and then like to
comment on them and then I just kind of
like okay I kind of see the
entertainment in this I think he just
needs to be on Twitch or something and
then uh twitch dud he'll make like a h
hundredth of the revenue he's doing he's
killing it with this God knows how much
he's making from this man it's it's
insane right I'll call the manager over
[Music]
give oh your turn yeah I he was helping
me give me just one second oh now hold
on
though do we really think he recruited
this lady and the cashier the old to
participate in this bit maybe not I
don't know
oh I just need a little excitement in my
life oh sure yeah I mean you can see her
a glimpse of her hair here no I don't
think he recruited any of these people
no I think he's so he went and cut in
front of her yeah that's her you can see
the glasses you can see the
[Music]
hair there she is caught her look at
that oh sh turn yeah I he was helping
just one second oh she just C so but
then so it sounds like she didn't cut in
front of he actually cut her he cut her
yeah but now I'm also hearing the
cashier who seems to be really helping
her a real person right so this is this
is kind of looking real at this moment
yeah go
away okay yeah you goad you go ahead
like this he's doing shtick here but I
think the situation might be real could
have a blessed
day yeah all right y got the beds got
the nasty [__] out the way thank you bro
now she's having problems at the front
you have to have this one karma's a
[__] wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait my God what happened there the he
was just checking out wasn't he okay my
understanding is this is two different
ladies the first lady who he claimed cut
him was an older lady and then he cut a
lady behind
him different cutting incidents yes
twaid act she just cut
me oh H have no CL what's going cuz if
you go if you go a little
turn okay yeah you go you go ahead oh my
God so scary when he's like that now
here's his friend so I mean we could
have a blessed
day yeah all right y' got the beds okay
so he's at the cashier he's buying this
stuff [__] out the way thank you bro
there was obviously a cut there at least
there's a hard cut here yeah like that
that could unclosed amount of time can
you just say to me aren't you the guy
that lives in an
RV right there is when it could have
happened could be but I mean imagine
you're at CVS and you're buying three
items that takes that interaction takes
10 seconds you don't have time to turn
around the phone and then film a bit
where you're whispering and [__] unless
the guy's like are you Austin MC Brun
I'm a huge fan and he's like oh word
he's like cool cool hey do something for
me say you live in a van that could be
random as [__] that seems plausible we
need to acquire the security table now
she's having problems at the front you
have to have this one karma's a [__]
and then they'll send you the the parore
where you scan she's having a problem
she's an old lady there is something
happening at customer service for sure
that he's capitalized on her card isn't
working that's what she gets oh no thank
you that's what she gets for cutting
me aren't you living in an RV have a
blessed day what aren't you living in an
RV yeah I am bro you're talking under
your
okay hold on he might not even be at I
don't think he's even trying to say he's
at the cashier something's this is
happening somewhere
else and someone just cruised up to him
no it's a cashier because in the next
shot I believe the guy's outside it
looks like no that's the lady I don't
think so watch he he's near customer
service overhearing the conversation and
then someone cruises up to him for
cutting
me aren't you living in
have a blessed day what aren't you
living in an the way his head
snaps this shit's funny man I think it's
might be real oh you think it might be
real now but the way his head snaps so
funny bless what aren cuz he's saying
that because he is being annoying to the
lady he's saying oh this lady's credit
card isn't working but and then it's
like Karma and then the cashier says
aren't you living in an RV why are you
[__] talking this lady that's how I see
it or or it could be I do think whoever
said that was overhearing him yeah that
and but it could have not been at the
cashier maybe he someone with her I
don't know yeah I am
bro says enjoy
Works later on he's an employee yeah
interesting I'm living in RV is that a
problem no I was just wondering like you
talking some crazy Wonder oh h just if
you you can't really make it out if you
go back yeah love Love's right he's like
cuz you're you were talking some big
[__] I think he that's crazy yeah I'm
living in RV is that a problem no I was
just wondering cuz like you be talking
some crazy stuff right now I was just
wondering he said you've been talking
what some crazy stuff right now he did
over hear the him talking about the lady
oh man this is really intriguing he's
actually being confronted by a hater I
can't I don't know on this one I I feel
like it could go either way this one has
to be real cuz of the lady this can't be
is way too like choreogra this this
confrontation could be a PL dude how is
this not a joke look how his head snaps
over like it's crazy funny karma's a
[__] there's no shot that this is a
real person this this is a real person
in the world reacting like this send you
the the barod where you scan it and then
card isn't working
that's what she gets oh no thank you
that's what she gets for cutting
me aren't you living in an RV have a
blessed day what no he's like completely
taken off guard on
this like hearing him [__] talk to this
lady and then all of a sudden aren't you
living in [__] RV his gentle like
voice when he's speaking to this guy
scares the [__] out of me wait okay I
think I understand what's happening CVS
they have a counter with multiple
cashiers next to each so there's a
community line if you been to like Ross
or one of these kinds of stores there's
like a a C shaped line and then from
there you walk up to the counter and
there's like three or four next to each
other yeah so she cut
him and then or whatever that's what he
says and then she goes to one cashier he
goes to the cashier next to her so
there's two different cashiers helping
both of
them and he is doing all this [__] and
the cashier can over here
sorry to cut you off right what's going
on next to him yeah so the lady next to
him that cut him off her card isn't
working so he says wow karma for you
lady yeah and then the cashier overhears
that it's like what do you mean Karma
talking [__] about this old lady you
live in an RV it's like confronting him
talking [__] about lady right no I I I
know that's the the thrust of it but
it's funny that you think this one's
real and cuz I'm I'm torn on this one
yeah I know cuz it's just so good it's
so [__] good it's too good that's the
thing it's too good the way it's just
here was like wait what what did you
just say and he laughes onto it directly
he too good yeah yeah I am bro you're
talking your breath [__] that's crazy
that's I'm living in RV is that a
problem no I was just wondering cuz like
you be talking some crazy cuz this is
out of character he's seriously getting
offended now and like trying to he seems
mad yeah and he never acts good like
that the another reason is this gives me
foozy IRL Vibes like half the stuff that
happened in his streams I would not
believe if I didn't see it live like I
would never believe any of that [__] if
it wasn't happening live and I could see
him encountering similar I situation if
this was live that'd be a lot easier to
tell if it was real or not right I mean
it'd be very easy to tell I feel like oh
yeah I was talking cuz a lady cut me
yeah
yeah I can't live in RV no you can't
he's talking [__] about me cuz I'm live
in RV that's crazy that's crazy and he's
working at CVS that is crazy that's mad
that's [__] up
bye no who the [__] he waving to who
waves back she actually waves back I
think that's an accident too I think
that's just a lady that lady waved back
I thought that was the the employee
because of the red shirt no it's an old
lady yeah I just think not the it's not
the lady that cut him that's a random
lady think he Wes to her she waving back
to him I think she just got cross she's
just nice wait what
maybe I want I don't know by I'm in RV
bye wait no he's filming her he's
targeting her yeah you're right yeah
what on Earth is going on here man I'm
living in I'm living in this video is
going to be analyzed for years like the
Kennedy assassination yeah [__] up
that's [__] up bye I'm living in RV
bye bye bye I mean that's real he's
driving off mhm so who is that lady
who's that lady oh must be the lady he
had a confrontation with she was
shopping that's that's what I was that's
a guy but I can't I can't tell it's
guy [__] up that's [__] up bye here
let's go frame by frame that's like a
teenager oh [__] yeah wait you're right
yeah that's the the cashier I think
there's no see that makes me not believe
it who what CVS employee just wears like
a red well they might just be recit CVS
or whatever
but why would they follow him out
because it's Austin maybe to record it
wait he has a phone in his hand he is
filming him
oh what he would do if he was like you
know he's obviously hating yeah and so
he's filming it so he came out to film
Austin if this is real Austin's having
the craziest life ever I mean this is
bananas that kid needs a postate if it
is we need definitely we need that video
so he's filming him and so Austin's
acting up RV bye bye bye I'm living in
RV I'm so sorry okay
wow that's a tough one if it is if it's
all real he orchestrated all that in
such a masterful way the way he shot and
look at ducky
right cute he's laying in two beds he's
so
funny
guys he just brought something out of me
just now that Sho ni welcome back to
chat Sho ni we did our first ban appeal
we did a ban appeal yeah he reached out
to me uh kind of out of the hadn't heard
from a minute man here we go he said
that he's sober and he's doing good now
and uh asked if we could unban him and I
said of course we can unban
you oh 20 oh my God wait how did wait
what the
[__] oh this is his uh chat history chat
history yeah from today I've been
snoring drain them all day all right
let's see what he's been saying I am
Dana sober I am Manda I am Elizabeth oh
hi Elizabeth good Michelle hi Mary thank
you he's doing the shoai show in the
chat yeah this is uh this was before uh
the episode like during the pre-show
okay that's that's totally fair it
continued later as well but since this
is the beginning of it uh Daniel
unblocked me they know I'm here he's
saying hi to a bunch of
people uh nope Angel here forever he
said because I don't wait my ass bro I
remember when H3 had 2500 Subs no you
don't wow he might how how there's no
way he was following me back then if
nobody following what if he was one of
the first
2000 like all other people in our I
doubt it I doubt doubt it's possible
though he is weirdly like in tune with
everything happening on the internet
yeah he might have me and Ethan are BFFs
thank you Daddy I've been so 19 days
they grow up fast congrats missed you
guys hi Ethan my Discord should I I
won't read his Discord even though he
wrote it
publicly okay and then he he just sent a
um he sent us a message that reads CVS
caught me sucking nitrous from whipped
topping
cans of course good stuff of course that
happened I believe that yeah I buy that
I hope that was more than 19 days ago
cuz yeah it break snor drain W thing
well he's talking about alcohol I mean
he didn't say he's not snorting whipped
cream cans oh okay so that's yeah he's
just talking about alcohol cool
okay okay I was watching the video back
can we go back in the CVS one more time
oh my go we're going back in this is the
zuder film all right just give me the
exact time stamp so I'm not floundering
around it's
44 seconds I'm sorry 44 minutes 44
exactly okay I got you right
here that's what she gets oh no thank
you that's what she gets for cutting me
yeah aren't you living in an RV have a
blessed day what aren't you living in an
RV yeah I am bro does it look like he's
mouthing out aren't you living in RV
that's what I was going to say earlier
but I didn't want to say he when after
he says what he like says the first two
words but it might be that his like mind
is echoing what he heard but let me
watch it is an interesting let me watch
let me watch oh no thank you that's what
she gets for cutting me yeah aren't you
living in an RV I didn't I didn't it's
about to have a blessed day what aren't
you living in an RV see he went RV oh no
I think that's that does look just an
echo in his brain I think he's mouthing
the other actor's lines if you go I
think it's just a coin it's just a
coincidence okay go go back to 44
seconds go little bit it looks like he
nudges to the left like watch like like
say l send you the the barcode you scan
it and then you is
working that's what she gets oh no thank
you that's what she gets for cutting me
wait
wait nah I mean it's possible but I
don't think it's
conclusive same with the mouthing thing
aren't you Liv in I think it's just a
coincidence it looks like it you're
right aren't you living in an RV have a
blessed day what aren't you living in an
RV yeah like nah yeah when assume it's a
coincidence I mean I I agree there's no
such thing as a coin that's you
thank you for saying so live
R all right so here's now he's
apologizing to the CVS kid bye bye bye
I'm living in an RV I'm so sorry guys by
the way I I should have mentioned but I
I did run a poll asking the chat if they
thought that encounter was real or fake
and 65% think it's
real I think
there's I think it's probably
real however there might be a mix which
is common with a lot of this content is
that it might be both might be
both could
be
wow he just brought something out of me
just now that nobody should see nobody
like this is Goofy wait look at the way
he looked out the window no I'm just
kidding okay that's not me I don't like
talking [__] about
people but that was wrong with him like
he just cut me off from my transaction
of me purchasing something from his
store to tell me aren't you living in an
RV damn you know how many people live in
their RVs like is that bad is that
wrong are you better than me because I
live in an RV no you're not this is not
serious right this is shtick is he mad
think he's playing pretending to be he's
being silly I feel like we're all equal
we are all one we're we're all in this
world together trying to win together
like there's no shot you would give this
speech after no that happened he's
trying to maybe gain sympathy actually
is what I'm
feeling God I'm so confused so I am
sorry that I made fun of him for working
at CVS that is not right of me I take
that back anybody who works at CVS I
apologize CVS is great store and you
guys deserve the best okay so again I am
oh he's getting ahead of the you work
CVS comment which by the way I can see
people getting mad about that sure you
work at
CVS yeah people are getting mad about
that and then him talking about the
lady's card having problem with her card
and the latest card her she was having
problem with her card I think oh yeah so
he's getting ahead of it yeah he knows
he just he flared me he flared me
up he flared
me there's no shot he's not kidding
around no he's getting again I apologize
I am sorry I will never do that again
the next time I go to CBS I will give
you a hug e don't touch me let's
continue the day I'm sorry CVS guy yeah
obviously I [__] up so
here here's what we need let me change
your mind we need Austin to call in wow
really really you want that do you want
me to try I absolutely [__] want that
wow okay
I mean absolutely we should try 100% he
should he can come in if he wants two
legends we need the CVS guy to calling
we need the CVS guy to confront him we
need to find out now that's a [__]
Bridge right there CVS guy and Austin
McBroom wow CVS guy if you happen to see
this message message us we can bring you
all together in one magical room truly
truly he Bridge build that bridge yeah
it's it's the bridge to the mind and the
Soul it's not even a we're not even
talking it's more than a bridge even
yeah it's a Stairway to Heaven more like
a Causeway but yeah Stairway to Heaven
Too your family's heart and soul yeah
yeah you're
beautiful thank you
Bert Tom oh Tom celic yes sir now we're
to get them there all right so p and
Bert Reynolds are like this guy they
yeah they're the same guy they have a
similar Vibe it's just alone I [__]
love Bert R it's just it's just alone
it's just alone this isn't my first road
are you kidding me they look they're
like the same human being mustache
mustache guys all right should I watch
this or is there we move on y okay so
this is a really weird new um vertical
here Austin returns to
school yeah he was teasing all day that
he had a big announcement this was
it he I guess has a lot of free time he
I don't know he's not working really
well he is working but his job is so
[__]
easy but do we believe him big
announcement in one hour he says all
right Snapchat fam are you guys ready to
hear my big announcement you guys are
ready no no you're
not I'm ready to tell you
though okay guys guess what Austin
McBroom is going back to
school yes I am guys and guess what I
got accepted at
UCLA Billy Madison okay I don't can you
just enroll in UCL that easily extension
school I think you can oh you think he's
doing the extension school yeah like I
know if you go to Community College you
can get into uccla if you transfer after
2 years but if you're just like a dude
who hasn't been to school in 15 20 years
years 30
years 20 probably can you just Cruise in
and be like hey let can I enroll I don't
I don't think I well I don't think the
uh not like this this is definitely fake
don't get me wrong but like sure you can
go back to school but UCL wouldn't they
don't oh no you'd have to apply like
anybody else that's probably right yeah
the extend they have like a it's
essentially is a community college it's
connected okay okay okay he says it's
for his Masters yeah so that was so
that's [__] well does he have a
bachelor's degree yeah so that actually
you could apply for a master's that
makes more sense to me if he has a
bachelor's already then you can apply
for a master
program why why do we know that he has a
bachelor's degree he played college ball
so I'm true okay good point yeah well
that doesn't mean he got a degree maybe
uh maybe a college recruiter saw his uh
ankle roll and said you got the stuff
yeah right well he did go to college we
know that that's a good point so does he
say what what's his master in this is
let's watch he says in Psych
psychology
psychology I mean that is like the
midlife crisis
degree he thinks psychology is just
psyching people out psych psych yeah I'm
a prankster so I'm here now as you can
see I put the fit on to match the school
so I'm coming here to get my masters
okay I mean go Bruins right you know I
got go Bruins my kids are going there no
there's no discussion go Bruins baby
that I I'm kidding because it's like 10
minutes from our house oh right well
there's that I thought it was just cuz
your dad was forcing you to [__] it no I
don't care about any of that I don't
care about Bruins College foot I don't
care I'll be if they're there I'll be a
big I'll turn into a fan right if they
care about it not going to go without
them sure however they are they are
disallowed from going to any other
school thank you if they go to any other
school they have to pay for it wow
which most people do have what a harsh
punishment that would be well I mean if
your parents are offering to pay for
college yeah know yeah you're like you
go to UCLA and I'll pay for everything
or you could be you can go against the
family and move 10 minutes not close to
me right lifetime of debt and go to go
to us that's how we control our children
people this is all a joke by the way
let's just be clear about that yeah
I got you HD cuz you know you know I got
to work my way up and uh for those who
don't know he wants to get a
PhD sure I already got my degree I
already went to college got my degree so
they accepted me here at you he'll soon
be a contemporary of Jordan
Peterson's fantastic a PhD in
Psychology hey and now I'm going for my
masters um as you guys know I'm working
on my mind I'm working on my body and my
spirit in order order for me to capture
the mind I got to understand and learn
psychology okay so I'm going to school
for psychology getting my masters school
for me starts today I have a class today
and I'm taking you guys with me yes we
doing that today so let's head over cuz
we're running a little behind so let's
head over right now I'm here at the
school now being laid on your first day
of school uh class is like a night a
reoccurring nightmare I have and parking
at UCLA [__] sucks dude mhm good luck
I've never tried
he's starting mid semester
too right I mean none of it nothing
makes to well we don't let's stop it's
not real no not real to him Dam we don't
need to pick apart every detail we
understand that this is not
real I don't know I don't know we head
over find some parking and then figure
out when my first class
is
um I don't know if I have any friends I
go here I'm going to be honest so I'm
going to need some help around friends
yeah wait wa wait how old is Austin he's
like 35 right 36 yeah 30 I don't know if
I have any college friends
yeah holy
[__] okay he's young 31 campus uh let's
go left let's go left he's a Sprite how
you doing I'm new here how you
doing how you guys doing I'm my God I'm
so excited going to school somebody's
dropping him off by the way hey so
excited I cannot wait for this [__] woo
straight a masters PhD I'm
coming excuse me do you know
what dude I'm vibing with this content
yeah I know he's winning me over I'm
about to download Snapchat this is Ace
Fest all over again yeah nah nothing
will ever make me download Snapchat dude
something other than them paying me
something about seeing him in person I
just I felt like I was close enough to
just dab him up it just felt so right
and I was telling Dan the story after
like wait did you you really dabbed him
up like that we were just cracking up I
think it may have been a little high but
it just felt right killed me well it
sounds like the vibe was right he does
you know he's a homie yeah yeah where I
park for school do we know where I park
he's asking the thank you my brother
I'mma come back and get some fruit from
you you guys got the best fruit yes you
do Happ at school excuse me do you know
where I park for school do we know where
I park thank you so much right there
thank you my brother I'm going come back
and get some fruit from you you guys got
the best
fruit okay iconic like that is
Iconic wait why does it keep playing
this what is happening oh thank you so
much right there ahead a little bit ex
so Snapchat has this other feature where
it doesn't it won't just autoplay if it
realizes that you're you're stagnant for
too long and it'll start looping the
video what yeah oh that's another crazy
ad yeah it's like meant to stop you from
uh ripping it I think it's meant to stop
you from being inactive and watching uh
ads they want to ensure the advertisers
that people are watching cuz they get a
higher CPM yeah but I heard this and I'm
afraid that this may come true with AI
and face recognition technology that
like they'll know if you're watching it
or not mhm
and if you look away they'll pause it
and say you have keep looking at the
screen if you want to watch get through
the ad yeah like I can see that
happening and that's [__] horrifying
yeah that sucks that would suck I'd
probably sto watching but then it's
everybody it's always
everybody Maybe YouTube It's Hulu it's
Netflix it could be the [__] cable
TV we need your eyes on the screen
scary
thought um go ahead
Justin you want a photo let's get a
photo come on I think you're in my
class I think you're in my class I think
you're in my class [__] come on seems
like a Disney movie where a kid wishes
to be an
adult all
right yeah it's big exactly
great big Z big Z here show them my
outfit show them my outfit my school fit
all right guys so I'm here on campus on
the Jazz dude he is out of
control look show show show them show
okay guys I'm ready for my first day I
have my fit on um so this is what I
thought was best to wear today I have
this here to match you see like colors
what going you see like colors just the
blue and there's some orange which is
not he's new he's new Austin world man
we're just living what's he looking at
just a [__]
weirdo here here no try it again bro try
this again everyone's [__] with me
today I yeah it keeps doing it okay here
we are again I'm here at UCLA show them
again show them again okay got to get my
energy back my mood back don't let
nobody don't let nobody tear you down
Austin I'm back okay so myit you guys
saw the shirt he is serving glasses
here's my Puma shoes okay I had to wear
no socks cuz everyone's Smarter with no
socks got my backpack yeah I know a
little bougie but it's all I had I'm
show you what's on my backpack is it
bougie okay is that a designer backpack
it looks like a kid's backpack right
here got my jacket cuz it gets cold
after 5 need that true got some
headphones never know what you want not
until listen nobody I got a wallet a
water and then that's a
$4,500 Louis Vuitton comic book back oh
that's just that is really ugly [__] it
says about to get robbed on
campus that is a that is just the
silliest backpack for an adult to walk
around with yeah 5.3k
retail
wow and zero school supplies oh yeah no
pens where's the pencil where's the
laptop that's the gag guys
this
book book ddg gave I don't know why I
need that the book is perfect got
perfect Mar yeah let me see that this is
this isend the most obvious bit of all
of them yeah like he's this is when he
leaning in
it I mean it's funny but it's obvious
yeah I like it more when existed in like
a in a Lial in between yeah but to be to
be honest I still don't know know how
much of it is real and how much of it is
fake I I have no idea I still think that
it's a gradient of like I think he is
getting divorced yeah I think him making
content after about
being a pathetic divorced guy is
intentional well I think leaning into it
I think he started and when people were
like dude this is pathetic he started
leaning he saw an opportunity which is
credit to him from a Content perspective
it is funny that was a good move and
it's a way to reclaim the other day I
think the the reason that I was
skeptical is because I didn't believe
somebody as egotistical as him would
debase himself like that but I think
Olivia did you say it earlier where the
the if he's intentionally being pathetic
then he owns it and it he I said that
you said it so that was my brilliant in
okay I'm sorry that is a good Insight
uh yeah I I I think that there's
something to that yeah that's his way of
like coping um but then again you got to
think back to that the head he was in
Katherine's
bed like how do you explain
that I I explained it the way that I
explained it the other day post breakup
sex I mean okay true true true true true
and they're they're friendly they're
friendly so that could be that could be
they hooked up the info I have right
here doesn't mean the divorce isn't real
I'm Lake though I got to hurry we got to
hurry R to late come
on wait a second all theories of mine
went out the window with this school Arc
now I just think he's the [__] Joker
I don't I can't I'm so lost now you're
Mor I feel like this clarifies things I
yeah but this is like so fake obviously
but it's so not funny that it's it's
just weird it is funny I it's it's crazy
I mean I think it's good like I see a
lot of people think saying they think
this is pretty funny in the chat so I
mean no it's it's funny like I find it
less funny as well it's like funny to us
it's funnier no I don't think so I think
it's funny that's what we do I think it
exists in its own world and it's funny
okay in its own world I do think
so I'm trying to get some like the way
that he's just [__] with people and
every I'm just so confused about
everything and I mean this one is fake
but there will be real [__] and we won't
know what's what yeah which reminds me I
need to do my like hourly check on him
yeah check him do not tell me my class
is way up there do not tell me I have to
walk all the way up there oh hell no the
stairs do set why the hell is a school
this big this is ridiculous no one needs
to have a school this damn big I'm with
them on all this come on man we got I
mean college campuses are massive the
UCS they're all huge yeah I mean UCLA is
like really big I guess yeah there
probably are at UCC you have to take a
bus to get to the other side oh it's
like on like a hill too right you see in
the forest on the hill [__] so spread
out
out yeah we got to go way up there are
you kidding me why is his friend coming
with them he's going to class his
assistant not going to class E why his
assistant going to class with him Dan is
this real
chat join this tour cuz I don't
knowell oh my God I'm sorry Hi how are
you sorry we're just no no no you're
good I heard your voice it's okay it's
okay I'm I'm can we help out with
something yeah I'm just looking for Mr
Peter's class I was joining tour cuz I
don't know where I'm going today oh okay
no worries oh he he tagged Along on a
tour yeah that's bananas that's bananas
hi it's kind of funny come here funny
bunny a you're so sweet we got some
breaking updates after we do this
one you're so
cute cute somebody in the chat said uh
you see Santa Cruz is the biggest you
see oh for real well that makes sense it
was just impossible to get
like I lived on the opposite side of
where the pool was it would take me like
an hour to get there appar somebody said
UCLA is the smallest you see by land
size which is crazy cuz it's still
pretty [__] Big's no way there's no way
there's no way there's no
way hi you're so cute lift him up a
little higher so you you got to share
ducky he's comfortable with the crowd
there he is there he is so cute sweetie
D my
you guys are matching today let me tell
you a funny story hit me last night
middle of the
night I wake up and there's something
very gently nibbling on my
toes ducky woke up and he started
nibbling on my
toes very gently didn't hurt at all like
hey it so funny wake up so cute and so
funny such a good boy so sweet such a
good boy a good
dog yeah
cute
cute look at that
face look at that face sweetest puppy
look at
it looking like what I
see all
right
scooby scooby dooby know where that is
um you said by the soccer field okay
yeah that yeah that'll be that way okay
thank you so much you guys have a great
day okay I'm going the right way you
guys really that sounds hard what is
a I knew that I knew that oh my God
that's so amazing so yeah it's like I'm
just I'm kind of running a little late
and I don't know where the hell I'm
going but they said Mr Peter that's
really that sounds hard what is a bite
and I don't know where the hell I'm
going you they said Mr Peter all right
his this istick what we have updates uh
AB um yeah here I'll send you his
Snapchat he's just like sweating balls
in his trailer in his RV rather cuz the
Heat's out oh so he's out of his
friend's house yeah this is from three
hours ago heat
H I think someone should report to the
campus police that there's a strange man
who's not a part of that Community
wandering the campus it's a good point I
think you're going have to keep skipping
through I think it's the only way oh
this is the source
baby thank you bro we're almost there
come on we have to hurry
we're wait a minute do y'all see that
Sunset just hit me just right bro how
long you been walking around cus that's
the that's it right there see that right
there hit me just right that's the angle
right there
I love that look look y'all it looks so
beautiful it's slowly dropping guys I
love that he stops and smells the Roses
yeah he
does dud he get to Mr Peter's class he
is so damn
silly
uhoh you think he was trying to make up
a name in Jordan Peterson the only
psychologist he could think of and he's
like Mr Peter I'm at the soccer field I
don't see [__]
what I started class at the class
supposed to start at 4:49 and so what am
I washing for keep skipping to get to
the how do I skip I can skip forward
there's a right wait you trying to show
them one from 3 hours ago AB yeah this
is at 21 hours ago we're going to have
to skip through like 200 videos to get
to it if you hover on the right side of
there's there's like three more videos
here okay okay here these are from 3
hours ago okay we're back we're back
rumors man I don't yeah well I know I
just assume that in 24 hours he probably
posted another 200 [__] Snapchats
let's see what Catherine's posting just
to do a little side project here before
I watch
that no don't don't don't don't don't
she's posting you can't yeah don't yeah
he's he's right it's what I was talking
about earlier wait what the the store
with the oh the the the toys they're
called okay got it got it got it God
damn it's hard to breathe here y'all
so they got the heater to work thank God
they got the heater to work but the
heater is now to damn hot I'm sweating
my ass off it's hard to breathe in here
God damn it's one thing after
another trying to get my breath back oh
my God you guys do not understand you
know what you got you know there's
nothing real at this point she is such a
diva it's boring now that it's
it's really just cring I agree it's not
it's not very watchable from from my
point of view now get out to get some
fresh air
that's I need yall help just watching a
really weird long sketch yeah with no
joke or point right at the end of this
he shows a text message exchange between
him and Catherine show I'm hot he's
eating chicken my on
chicken that's funny that is funny the
chicken I like
hry y'all so yeah that might be the one
also let me show you around fix up the
place a little easy come you know the
best
situation so in the bathroom got
some how much I
got too you're not going to be a to go
back if I miss it I missed it I can't
like all right y'all so why these
cookies I can't do this actually I found
I found making cookies without a sheet
yeah he put the cookie dough on just the
rack in the oven I wish I could go back
but I don't know I don't think you can
left you can you can now just saying if
you go around all right you know what I
I got to get out of this yeah I got to
get out of this thank you Austin it just
turned cringe that's weird the CVS one
was such a hit and then just downhill
immediately because that one is like cuz
it felt real best ones are theable real
part fake mhm those are the good ones
yep the fully orchestrated ones are not
good what he needs to do is just put
himself in public situations where he's
a
menace so that real people are comp you
know complaining with him and calling
him out
right you know this was his final story
this text message exchange I'm don't
know what to gather from it though he
posted this text exchange with C
Katherine
says and I booked a trip for the girls
trip next month I was going to talk to
you about it in person I just have to
get flight now but the hotel is
confirmed okay no steel Jack what does
that mean steel is one of his kids I
believe okay since they have school it's
better to wait for a break yeah because
two days isn't long enough anyway but I
got a villa confirmed in the Mal the
mald for spring break if you'd like to
go if it's this one holy [__] wow thanks
for the
invite you were invited already when I
spoke to them about what I needed for
the
family
fake I don't know why this such R I
don't know what the [__] is going on why
we I don't understand anything anymore
I'm out I'm out I'm out don't send me
anymore with peace and love no more
Austin MC Brom videos peace and godamn
it and love fight fight but now let's
talk about my real passion in life wait
keep going re fight fight fight
fight
fight that's not how I remember this the
the speech in the you know and it makes
me Saving Private R yeah that's not I
remember Gandalf
[Laughter]
speech all right I know a bathroom and
then well ducky God damn such a menace
are we going to we going to do the timer
how long we' been going uh four uh four
2:45 all right so we have plenty of time
for Cav Cav kind of maybe one we'll have
to kind of SL 45 minutes yeah that's
enough of Cav Cav I guess so whatever we
manage to cover it's enough yeah we
probably just we should just do the
failure one we should skip the weird
conspiracy one that one's good though I
haven't seen the failure one though so
that shit's new to me yeah all right
I'll be right back I'm going to go the
bathroom 4 minutes and 6 seconds
starting now there it
is Val just donated five bucks their
first Super Chat ever I love you guys
thanks
Val Val Hina
josa
[Music]
uh Ethan just said Jimmy just posted his
first podcast if you want to check it oh
he started texting me again too I don't
want check that here's Jimmy not
interested not I'm with you on that
one sorry not interested uh
Reena donated $20 I hate to be that guy
but my 21st birthday was yesterday
you you don't hate to be that guy don't
lie I'm in a I've been a fan since I was
12 I remember the day my friend showed
me the old Channel I watched every video
that was on it I love what the A3 family
has become okay that's really nice Z 21
[__] you thank you thank
you Manuel Lopez Manuel Lopez uh I fell
asleep at the wheel while watching your
show last week and got into an accident
love you
guys is that real
what [__] I hope you're okay that's
crazy don't Pride when you're tired dude
yeah don't do that [__] I hope you're
okay um it's very dangerous love to you
and caugh that one caught me off guard
Caesar said uh donated 10 bucks and said
hey today is my birthday I would love
for yall to come try our Mexican
restaurant I mean I'm I'm always happy
birthday um also when yall play the
original intro it's always a tear jerker
yeah Zach's been uh incorporating that
more um you said come try your Mexican
restaurant you didn't say what it is
yeah I go I don't know how to try it if
is it in LA if it is I'm there I'd try
it sometime
sure what are those uh forgive me for
being a gringo here um what are those
tacos they're like fried and then
there's like the dipping sauce to
them I've seen I know you're talking
what are they all around Instagram reals
uh I don't know if that has a special
name it probably does but it looks so
good so Caesar
make me some of those T you make some of
those uh super duber full donated 20 uh
gifted podcast M oh you talking about B
is that what it is yeah it's oh I think
that's right B Taco yeah yeah I think
that's been getting popular
lately uh some uh Emily donated $50 at
the beginning of the show so we love
your show our dog Rico loves to bark at
the rabbit in your background that's
cute if everyone could vote vote for
Rico for America's favorite pet it would
mean the world he's in 10th Place
where's that love you fam just look at
his smile we
love is is that like a known thing
America's favorite
[Music]
pet let's see let's see the rankings can
we see Rico right
now um I'm on the
website Hall of
Fame
registration is free is it on their
Instagram or something I don't know
where I would find this never heard of
America's favorite pet
before well I'll look around Ethan's
back what was the time you had 27
seconds to go oh you were I took my time
too I'll be honest I grabed some granola
wow I can hear that on the way and back
good both times it's really good granola
yeah you know granola has so many
calories in it
I I I love grol I used to eat it all the
time
but a bowl of that [__] is like five 600
calories wow I think it's really
intense I'll I'll show you guys let me
get the bag so I can eat more I eat that
all the
time no I'm not I'm not worried
about she from Iowa is that the honey
one are you from Iowa
this is the O Honey granola you're from
Iowa Poss a
bowl
okay one3 of a cup which is like
nothing that's like a few
flakes 2/3 of a cup is
250 do we have a cup here I'm curious
how much is that um we should get a move
on with the c c thing we're going to run
that
time I know as interesting as granola
calories
are dude that with some
cir tell i b did it's crazy hey suck
these balls all right let's move on to
my fave Ryan Kavanaugh we know him love
him um
beta
beta let me get to it so he posted the
long
awaited let me actually you know what
Dan I got to do this before we get into
this let me just show you my favorite
parts of his weird conspiracy interview
okay here is Ryan telling an
anecdote about how someone from the
Massad was stalking him oh yeah this
this
is this is great I I I think the context
is during the bankruptcy with relativity
yeah he's explaining how there was a
vast Hollywood conspiracy to silence him
yeah and and the Israelis were involved
oh then I think the context is even he
hired this guy to go out to try to find
out the real identity of the Wikipedia
mods you caught that right I maybe I
didn't get that far but that's awesome
he was saying he hired a PA to go stalk
the a
pi that's crazy it is crazy it's really
crazy it's a lot I must have missed that
I heard him talking about this guy and
then he said that his he said they both
together he says both mods are together
and they live on a ranch together or
some [__] what I swear to God that's
what he says well let's just let's watch
let's hear what he
says well this is the Mad part but yeah
go ahead I don't know why it's just
loading it 17 I was uh hosting an event
for one of the um potential Sheriff
candidates and I was asked if I could
have a co-host who was a well-known Pi
um exmad Israeli um pi and in the middle
of the event I went up to introduce
myself to him and he's like oh I know
you better than you know yourself I'm
like wait what he's like oh yeah I've
pretty much read all your emails I've
follow I've seen everywhere you've gone
I know how you live I'm like what are
you talking about I thought it was
joking and he said no no no he's like
when you were in your hedge fund hostile
takeover I was hired by the group of
people who didn't want you to get out of
um put you into the hosel put you into
the chapter 11 and didn't want you to be
able to raise the money um and I was
given an unlimited budget and at the
time I had I I was flying a lot to go
raise capital and getting a company out
of a chapter 11 is a pretty big effort
um so they gave him a g he's like I had
a G550 and unlimited budget and I
anywhere you went I went if you landed I
landed behind you it's like I had people
in your office servicing your copy
machines I had people implanted
everywhere you went I'm like what' you
find goes that you he actually said that
you're really boring like I was hoping
you do some really exciting things like
you land you go to a meeting you take
back off you go home um and uh and I
laughed and I and I I said well isn't it
illegal for you to tell me he's like no
no I had a NDA that's up now
um not it's not the NDA that's illegal
it's the
stalking accessing your emails and [__]
and I'm like and I asked him I said what
was the intent what do they hope to get
also all of the best uh top exmad um
Private Eyes they they tell the people
that they do this to everything just a
couple years later that's part of prot
that's that's part of protocol that's
how you build a a good uh Client List is
by betraying all of their secrets to
everyone just so you know if you ever
hire me I'll tell everybody everything
about my job for you
yeah uh he this is the big Li ever this
is he's skitso posting I don't know how
else to say it and I'm sorry if that's
insensitive but this is this is some
real wait the background in his office
is strikingly similar to what it looked
like
[Laughter]
here took a little
inspiration God this was crazy all four
of them eh just to be just to be clear
Ryan Kavanagh Accused by ex partner here
it says that clearly written there I
think it's clearly written there yeah I
it's like to the naked eye very
visible cues by ex partner
yeah that was fun good
times time you want a meeting did you
realize that investors dropped I like I
did have a lot of investors drop I just
thought it was a negative press he's
like well no we did two things I
coordinated with this firm called
Rubenstein in New York to help plant
negative articles so any how is that not
defamation where you at
Rubenstein he's like yeah Rubenstein was
hired me to defame
you when I could kind of add an err of
Truth to try to make it seem realistic
but also I would tell them who you were
meeting with and they'd go behind you
and try and convince them to not invest
with you and I was just like in shock
and um so he like damn dude that's crazy
that's for sure how you would react to
finding out that your entire life for
the last 10 years have been manipulated
but he go this is just a private
investigator but now he's talking to Big
Time Business people trying to persuade
them not to invest with Ryan like the
premise makes no sense well that guy was
hired by those big time by by the
Hollywood Elite by the
cabal the Jewish cabal oh wait that's
the real irony about all this yeah is
that whoa oh oh ducky Jesus dude D did
that the oh it didn't activate the
button okay the button just
fell and it didn't fall in such a way
that it actually activated it thank you
all right so that's him talking about
the m i like whenever people tell these
um tall tales about mad they're like
these magical
incredible uh they're you know this just
emerged out of The Ether to just reveal
to him all this information also if I
will also say don't you think if if that
story is true
like he ran into this guy and this guy
told him all of that it was at that
point that he was being [__] with
right like whatever that guy was telling
him is not true but he is somehow
manipulating Ryan with that information
and this [__] guy I don't I don't
follow him like if he had this encounter
M and this guy came up and was like Hey
I used to work for the Israeli
government but now I I'm a private eye I
stalked you for the last like eight
years and I'm just letting you know if
that encounter happened that guy was
[__] with him at that point the
stalking didn't happen in the past
whatever manipulation is happening was
started with that
conversation okay that's more plausible
frankly right yeah I think someone was
just [__] with you
bro that wikip talking about Wikipedia
he goes totally off the rails play and
plays in all of this and what they
really are
well so it's a little independent of
this interesting enough and I think my
one of the reasons I really wanted to
come on and talk about it is I don't
know that the mainstream meaning the
same people who kind of I want to say
mainstream the the people who turned um
and were able to manipulate the press
and the narrative um have you yet
figured this out and yet I think it's
starting to something and once it's
figured out I mean you can literally
rewrite history in in the way they want
and I it scares me so it was interesting
how this happened which is um you know
bear in mind he's talking about his
Wikipedia page I kind of had this attack
and it's not that big of a deal dude
yeah [__] Wikipedia he also called
you mainstream and then corrected
himself and didn't want to give you the
title of mainstream he's mainstream yeah
not me I could never have that title No
went through a hard time eventually you
know when you make 200 movies and when
you build you know a studio from scratch
glazing himself up you know get drunk
and drive times oh he mentions that in
this interview too oh God there's so
many good moments do we have them all oh
cuz there's one where he goes oh yeah
and he he does this thing we like so
yeah I got this DUI I mean a wet and
Reckless it was reduced to a wet and
Reckless and then they just keep talking
about it like
he it's really something I got
everything yep list all the things you
said earlier that comes back up you
can't keep it down forever so they they
suppressed it for a while and I think
they kind of you know wasn't a threat to
them anymore and so by 20 he has his
[__] UCLA diploma behind him too I
know wasn't [__] wanking off yeah he
talks about it too how like the I forget
what publication was but they said he he
did graduate there based on their
reporting and he starts fighting with
them about it in this video too it was
kind of back and my clear and fine one
of the things that was always on the top
but I never understood that was always
fine was Wikipedia and what I mean
always fine is what I mean by always
fine is that we could manipulate it
write our own [__] yeah and have full
control control over
it and this by the way this is me
alleging things I don't know for sure
I'm just you know doing we know at some
point doing a joke well that's proven he
admits it he adits it in this to [__]
with his Wikipedia page it's crazy all
right I got to just play for it was
pretty much like a balanced um summary
of me like I guess what you would expect
if you opened up an encyclopedia at that
point in time and I just presumed it was
a company I can comfortably say that
that is completely false it was the
biggest dumbest silliest puff piece yeah
of a page ever no because you can see it
all you can see it all it made no
mention of any of his numerous failures
none zero mention it was all fluff so
that is not balanced in any way no had a
bunch of people that did factchecking
like any other kind of public journal
and you know just was neutral and was
just there to report kind of report
facts or state facts and you know I
remember looking at it and it was very
positive in general talked about all the
movies I made and me creating you know
the Marvel structure and doing the first
Netflix deal creating relativity real
and the sports agency but it also had
where Dude where's it all now you did
all these great things okay where where
is it also what is this Frame behind it
is that a TV with a little thing on it
or is it oh I see it's a big frame with
a couple things down it's so he made a
little collage doesn't it look dumb when
there's so much black space yeah it's
horribly laid out cuz there's not that
much [__] he doesn't have enough to fill
it out relativity went through a chapter
11 and this year and um you know 2016
and then I bought it back and resold it
and it had in there that in 2006 I had a
uh wet and Reckless which is
a just below a DUI what's what do you
mean just below a DUI were you drunk or
not a DUI is from a from driving Under
the Influence yeah from a legal
perspective that is a lesser charge
right but it seems like it just kind of
get a wet and Reckless if they're caught
driving drunk a rich Hollywood producer
like you get a DUI no that's what you
get who as he said has ties to the LA
Sheriff's Department true true as he
likes to brag about it was
not a a puff article it was factual it
was what you would expect and you know
it was mostly good but had the stuff in
there that was you know also not my
proudest moments and I was fine with
that it did not uh what but whatever but
it wasn't actually until I got into a
strangely unexpected war with a um a
professional um troll I'll call him a
YouTube blogger but all he really is is
a PR hey I take
uh I take offense to that they call you
a YouTube blogger yeah he keeps calling
me a blogger
this runs a social media company he
thinks I'm a blogger is he 80 I hav
never heard that word in like 20 years
YouTube blogger and professional troll
are you blog blogger that's like what my
mom would say about YouTube video what
yeah it's awesome troll that I saw what
Wikipedia really was and um by the way
if you if I'm talking too much you want
to inject in there I'm happy to redirect
it but asleep you know I I can also just
keep going on how vide whole time I'm
sorry if I'm talking too much yeah she
doesn't talk like at all which I loved I
didn't I didn't cuz whenever she talks
it's just like so stupid she doesn't
talk at all and then she kind of like
interrupts him at the end she okay we
got to go oh yeah it was an hour
deadline so she had to cut him off for
some reason this show this super highend
show right they had to control the
duration but whenever she talks she's
like yeah and it just means about like
you know how the government is trying to
censor us and they don't it's like dude
it's
Wikipedia uh long and short is that so I
helped I co-founded a company called
triller and within triller um which I I
not really involved in anymore other
than co-founding and owner chunk um I
built I'm not involved anymore I'm not
really involved I just co-founded it and
own a chunk of it I think he used to be
on the board and he's no longer on the
board that's what he means I think
gotcha yeah okay he's never he's not
that was probably a good move yeah
although it didn't help it still going
down in
flames the damage is done my
friend and it's
live did the six largest digital sorry
six highest grossing pay-per-view in
history which was something that I
personally conceived and produced and
came up with did it make
money cuz I'm pretty sure that they lost
a shitload of money on that event
talking about the Jake Paul one right
that's the one when he hired like Justin
Bieber yeah there was like a million
celebrities there everyone's like what
the [__] uh what's his name uh SNL guy
oh yeah Pete David was posting it yeah
oh right yeah Jake Paul versus Ben ask I
forgot about that Pete Davidson asking
uh Jake Paul about the New York Times
article oh yeah that's right added to
the savy what are you chewing on
there ducky what is
that what is that oh it's a chew oh he's
good what is that it's all chewed up
looks crazy
um sorry what were we talking about Jake
Paul Ben asking yeah did it lose money
is there any about that pretty sure it
was a massive
flop 2019 highest grossing in history
there's no way that's true yeah that
seems
unlikely could easily fact check that I
feel like yeah and the first highest
grossing digital pay-per-view in history
oh digital and I put Jake Paul as a
fighter on that undercard and you know
he was kind of at the time I'll just say
somewh of a fledgling YouTube blogger
that
he was not a fledgling YouTube blogger
is he try is he about to say he made
Jake Paul that is kind of that's what
he's saying oh [__] here you go Jake you
you you did this you were involved in
this [__] I suspect and now this dude's
saying he made you so we did not pay a
lot of money too and
ultimately he you know knocked out Nate
and it was a viral moment which led me
to them say let's go do an event with
Jake Paul starring and that was the Jake
Paul a viral moment huh a viral moment
when he knocked him out and he's
bragging about that what makes something
a viral moment
Ryan when the video goes viral on the
internet that's all we ever did wait
hold hold on this is actually might be
an interesting legal yeah argument he
says he's glad it went viral us talking
about it is part of that if like it's
not our fault that he got knocked out in
30 seconds well of course well so here's
the thing the judge pretty much already
said that it's fair use right okay so
they're not so it's all about this
unlisted [__] video with 60 views
stupid like this
whole [__] thing is about an unlisted
video what the URL was visible on the
screen like barely I mean you I don't
think you could even make it out with
the naked eye uh it's had 60 views 40 of
them are from him and keemstar talking
about it pretty sure
yeah and which was obviously very
successful and I think uh we spent tens
of millions of dollars on the event and
because it was such a young audience in
digital I saw something that um was
quite shocking which is we had probably
50x pay-per-view eyes digitally pirated
in stolen and people were profiting off
of that so our lawyers had told triller
you know Dana White and the UFC when
this happened actually sued
people who pirate it and so triller and
its board which is a multi-billion
dollar company not no it's not it's
worthless you couldn't pay me to take a
[__] invested interest in that some
little company that I run um decided it
was going to do something actually One
Step better which is it was going to
come publicly and give people 30 days
who legally pirated to just pay the
$49.99 and get a release and if not it
was going to go after them and it went
after I don't know five or six sites who
picked up the stream and illegally sold
them and um I kind of wasn't involved I
just you know knew they were doing it um
and then one day someone called me and
said you know this this this podcast
h3h3 and it was named Ethan Klein shout
out I don't I don't understand wow out
there Patriot
TV this guy knows nothing about me and I
believe him at this point but he still
misss the podcast name what h3h3 podcast
why is he why do people say that like I
understand why old fans would say it but
why the [__] would Ryan say it just well
it's your Twitter handle and stuff too
so he probably I guess recognizes the
booze
talking allegedly that's a joke what did
you type love first highest grossing
well he said well I feel he said it was
the first highest grossing
can't be Bose it's the first highest
what does that mean it's yeah if it was
the first it must be the highest were we
able either or were we not able to fact
check that's the stats it was according
to Jake Paul initially and if what Jake
Paul initially reported then it would
have been one of the top grossing of all
time I'm trying to find if there's a
more that's the thing uh I I'm finding
similar things where there aren't like
official numbers it's more just like
self com yeah from Jake and other people
involved so well he did it okay all
right
whatever this guy's like just trashing
on you on his podcast I'm like I've
never heard of this guy why would he be
doing that and they're like they say
you're suing him and I'm like I've never
heard of him why would I sue him and Ne
kind of ignored it and then over the
next month they're like this guy's done
like 30 podcasts on you and then it was
like 50 and then the number changes
every time he talks about it like he'll
do an interview like one week after the
other and he'll be like he did 40 he did
50 it's like bro just pick a number yeah
he he uh apparently on a podcast said
something like I think he looks like
Harvey Weinstein and actually it's funny
because I actually watched this and um
and people were like n now you're
stretching and then he decided oh I'm G
to start this trend and he kept saying
Ryan looks like Harvey Weinstein so he
actually created a website which is
really funny called it's really funny
thank you thank you very much we're
gonna add that to the website he
endorses it that's why he tried to sue
our like web domain to and accused us of
like stealing his identity or some [__]
yeah does Ryan Kavanaugh look like
Harvey wiin it is funny though I agree
it's very funny made games where you can
like scroll my face to his face and the
implication obviously there is trying to
make it seem like I'm like Harvey
Weinstein no you're not Harvey Weinstein
putting words in my mouth you're not
like har it's the opposite bro it's to
dis to say you're two different people
I'm drawing the differences that's the
whole point of the website man and I
think I take great offense at any
suggestion of of anything else happening
yeah and the domain is a question it's
everything is a question it's not a
statement does Ry no it's the answer of
course but after watching the yeah after
you learn after you learn yeah after a
while you know um but it got so bad that
um hey Ryan what does it say else on the
website if you scroll down all the way
and there's like a bullet list of all
these things like what
is that's why I don't understand like
this is why are you calling attention to
this website
sir I don't know but I'm loving it site
on his sorry podcast it turns out this
guy has 7 million followers and i'
literally never heard of him and he was
doing a podcast on me daily but he
wasn't just doing a podcast he was
misrepresenting like things like I sued
him
um he said he won you know he said oh
okay that's material like you just got
on about how you're like the running
this huge business and you're the guy
there and it's like well you
are you are triller I mean what the [__]
do you want from me pretty much he put
up um things like daily variety um and
Hollywood Reporter is on his background
as you can see I have daily variet in
the background when they Nam me billion
dollar producer and
he
articles as his headline and it was like
um Ryan kavana used a Ponzi scheme and
he had removed words to make that seem
like I actually done a Ponzi scheme okay
hold on I I remember I know that when we
did this I intentionally kept the text
big enough so that it was visible to the
naked eye because I just wanted it to
lay out nicely cuz it was too wordy so
like I feel like This is highly visible
Accused by ex partner yeah it's big it's
visible it's readable and and that was
intentional because I I didn't want
people to get the the any other you
know because he was accused by by his ex
partner later retracted which he
retracted but like whenever I'm talking
about it I'm pretty specific about he
was accused by his ex- partner but it
was later retracted which is an
important detail
versus you know this this teeny little
nothing that never was talked about
pissing contest between me and a guy
attired um and oh yeah he he makes these
wonderful excuses about everything so
apparently that lawsuit was just a
pissing contest between some dude he
fired yeah awesome sure he continually
does this about all the accusations
against and went to his people and said
listen everybody should post an uplink
this and he started Reddit threads and
um subreddits and he's on discords I was
probably getting 20 to 30,000 death
threats a day dude this was my favorite
this is the you did it you liar he was
getting 20 to 30,000 death threats a day
you are insane bro what would that look
like 20 to 30,000 death threats what do
you
mean what canot believe said that also
the I I shouldn't feel bad for the lady
but I I can't help but feel kind of bad
for her like she's a Looney Tune how the
[__] could she possibly know what the
[__] he's talking got to be lost at one
point she Compares what Ethan's doing to
the Soviet Union rewriting history
because yeah because that's their whole
shtick and she doesn't know what's
happening Ryan's the one who just
[__] photoshopped out people from a
photo that's memory hole yes it's
literally like the Stalin meme dude yeah
that is literally Stalin at least Stalin
took out the hands though right Stalin
was way more
careful um I that that part I was just I
can't said that no I 30,000 death
threats bro that would mean like okay
hold on let me do some math 24 hours in
a day we know that obviously so let's do
30,000 divided by 24 so it's 1,250 per
day 1 per
hour per wait what it's just a not like
his phone is just like blowing up oh
yeah that's per you said 30,000 a day
yeah it's
1,250 per hour wow Jesus wait 1,250 per
hour and then if you divide that by 60
he was he was getting 20 per second no
20 per minute 20 per minute
kill yourself kill yourself
[__] oh [__] dude what the
hell um he started telling me to go
after my my exwife who's my best friend
and mother my child she was getting
death threats they were they were just I
mean it was to the point where I
couldn't ignore it anymore so I mean
listen I I hope that's all that's untrue
but the fact that you said 20 or 30 ,000
per day as I'm not taking any of this
seriously you lost credibility there's
zero credibility unreliable narrator
absolutely I actually started to resp
publicly which is true the stupidest
thing I could do um and I'll be to
Wikipedia in one second um and all
sudden what are we talking his podc I
didn't realize someone had said to me
what happened to your Wikipedia and I'm
like what do you mean what happened to
my wi I looked she's like it was
like in his mind this is the line that
no body should
cross like I had nothing to do with this
[__] okay but like in his mind of all
the [__] he's like you crossed the line
buddy you were you were sending him
30,000 death threats a day but you touch
Wikipedia can you imagine how [__] up
that' be 20 you'd have to have like a
huge sophisticated bot net like
multinational botet I mean I think he
thinks that's what's going on he also
thinks he was being stalked by mad so he
might have a paranoid personality
disorder genuinely I'm starting to kind
of think that there's something
something going on do you think he's
reading at all the way his eyes are
scanning he's like he's going left right
left right looks like he's reading off
of a script or
something now Alfredo's getting annoyed
I can
tell although he might he might
sometimes he gets annoyed and then he
starts playing with them it's hard to
tell or you're just being so
distractive ducky
uh let's keep going as if I was Bernie
mid off meets uh Jeffrey dmer I mean I
didn't say that but that's a pretty good
I like that you might have said that oh
did I Jeff we we've mentioned Jeffrey
dmer a few times so I could potentially
that sounds like something you'd say
well that's funny that is funny I mean
that's a good compar I like what
realized someone had said to me what
happened to your Wikipedia and I'm like
what do you mean what happened to my
wikip I looked and it was like nobody
said that you were looking at it you
were name ing my dude wait this whole
self-reporting about Wikipedia coming up
is fantastic I told you this one's so
good D yeah no you're right we might
have to wait on the um I think we have
to because we only this is socking like
I don't want to I don't want to skip
anything yeah I think you should give it
the time it deserves it's so good we can
talk about failure on Friday uh Jeffrey
Dalmer so I went on and I'm like tried
to Lodge a complaint and as soon as I
like so first of all bro you don't Lodge
complaints to Wikipedia because your
personal page doesn't say what you stuff
that you think is makes you look dumb
and bad or incorrect that's not how
Wikipedia works
bro so he's like yeah so I went to
Wikipedia and told him what's the deal
why why can't I change my my page back
all this Wikipedia language they like
jump down my throat and all these people
are texting me like you violated the
rules you're not allow no okay he goes
all these people are texting me who [__]
is you mean like the people you're hired
to maintain your page like who the [__]
would T I think uh I think he is just a
boomer I think by texting he means he
was receiving messages on wikkipedia
because remember we followed all that
there was like all that drama on his
talk page where they were all's just
this account is clearly Ryan Kavanagh
you can't edit your own page which is
like yeah boohoo Ryan that's the policy
you like they don't want that's how it
remains credible he acts like it's not
credible that's how it remains credible
so that people can't [__] write
whatever they want about you're the one
trying to make it not credible by
editing yourself like that's the problem
this is my own speculation but based on
how many articles he's responded to and
they had to change stuff and just his
behavior in general he just wants to
know who he could threaten like who who
can I send a letter to well it gets
really disturbing to because like I said
he he gets into how he basically
stocked uh had a pi stock them the the
mods or I don't know I don't know if he
found out who they were or what mhm it's
pretty crazy though roast alone put
comments on your own page not Co he put
a hit on Thro I'm kidding I heard thr
was exmad yeah he has to be he has to be
and um I just was like I'm not sure what
I'm violating but this is all false and
and it's defamatory and it shows up on
first position and bro you are
self-reporting so bad you nobody gives a
[__] he goes it's the first position and
it's just got all this mean [__] in it
that's Wikipedia also he's obsessed with
the first position like he he's exposing
how like he's into all this SEO and
maintaining this Wikipedia page and
stuff he right oh yeah he's doing all
that in my opinion allegedly for about
eight months um there were people who I
think were coming to kind of my side of
things within this Wikipedia ecosystem
where it would get revers verted back to
the old one mean the the the one that
was done prior to his involvement and
then it would get reverted back to it
like a completely Rewritten version and
then reverted back and then reverted
back and after about eight months of
going back and forth and and people were
texting me on the side who didn't know
me through like Instagram saying we're
on your side this [__] you know
we're trying to help you the hord the
hordes of his uh loving fans are
watching this Wikipedia editing take
place we're with you my friend we're all
watching your Wikipedia Pages uh log
book you remember when he stocked Thro
onto the Shrek
Qui allegedly oh my God wait no I
thought is that I thought we knew that
that was him but I think
well what was the name of the US it was
a long it was a long time ago but
remember it was like somebody somebody
found Thro on the Shrek Wiki and was
like hello Thro I found you oh I
remember it it was fantastic but I don't
remember I guess we who knows it could
be somebody just posing as him or
something but I don't know was if the
name said his name or what it was very
funny though I sent the the
initial nice
to we've got oh this so this was this
was so good apparently what's alleged
here or
speculated thanks for just opening the
Reddit
logo oh it was an account called found
you 35 and they sent a message and said
hi Thro pleasure to finally meet you
you've been a very busy boy maybe we
should talk sooner than later dude
thinks he's jigsaw I'm
obsessed whoever wrote that which I
don't know who we don't know for sure we
don't know but it does sound similar to
a message loved on so that's kind of
what we based it off too that's a very
very similar message I got oh wait this
okay this gives it away he says pooki
around here somewhere cuz that's another
person he's constantly uh obsessed with
calling out oh that it has to be him
we might have talked about on the show
evidence is pretty compelling it's
compelling comp found you 35 bro it's
Wikipedia or die anyway this is all
alleged this is all speculation based on
what we're reading there yeah good stuff
though eh I'm telling you man been a
very busy
boy you've been a very busy boy
Thro were you know Wikipedia editors or
whatever they were saying and um you
know you're being uh what do they call
it vandalized on your
Wikipedia and then all of a sudden I got
a text from him saying the people that
Ethan Klein is paying to defame you um
got no one said that because first of
all it's not true so he's saying
somebody told me Ethan Klein are paying
people how do you know
that uh a senior editor I forgot there's
a there's a name for a person who's like
aor I know that and there's only like a
couple 100 of them dude that's awesome
so it's gross to senior admin [__]
Legend yeah maybe it's cuz you
threatened to sue him and you're talking
mad [__] and maybe maybe he doesn't like
you from that I mean he's plenty of
reason not to like you but also he's a
very dedicated Wikipedia moderator so he
takes his job seriously too Ryan right
so they we can no longer help you
they're going to be able to write
whatever they want and so I kind of got
close with a couple people who say are
Wikipedia experts and I just said can
you guys get a job dude he has way too
much free time what are you doing uhhuh
I got I got I kind of got in good with
some of the top Wikipedia I brought
together a think tank of the top
Wikipedia
Minds what
dude what I do here so I sent in
multiple letters to Wikipedia I started
doing my research and I realized there
is no
Wikipedia yeah you can't send letters to
Wikipedia asking for you to change your
own page dummy
you think it's like a place like it
exists well I'm curious what this
Revelation is he's about to Wikipedia is
a they call themselves a charitable
organization they have hundreds of
millions of dollars in the bank they
send out these emails to people every so
often saying you know oh we need your
donation even though they have millions
hundreds of millions of dollars all
right Ryan let's be careful about
accusations of Charity
impropriety I think Habitat for Humanity
will has some questions for you right
buddy they don't run anything they
actually just basically pay for the
storage space and pay themselves fat
salaries they don't I love how he's just
coming after the whole institution don't
interject they don't intervene they have
no fact checking and all of these people
dude Wikipedia is amazing honestly it's
one of the best things about the
internet it's one of the last good
things about the internet yeah like it
is such an amazing website and it and
and frankly over the years it's gotten
really in my opinion credible it's
become very very very somewhat I
mean you always got to you always got to
dig a Little Deeper you in the comedy
world the last take a little grain of
salt but but yeah I mean it's a it's a
good starting point I mean it's like a
it's like an encyclopedia exactly and
defense literally everything yeah who
actually create the content it's it's
content by popularity so how many people
V it how many people you know agree with
them and so in the case of something
like Ethan Klein where it turns out he's
got you know 7 million follow yes 70
billion followers followers who are now
that I've done my research between 14
and 19 years old oh yeah he says our
fans are between four based on his
research our fans are between 14 and 19
years old for sure yeah great which is
by far our least popular demographic and
you don't have 7 million followers
anywhere you don't even have 7 million
subscribers on the three seven follow
real followers no I'm talking about you
you don't have 7 million subscribers
even on Productions I'm assuming he's
adding them all together or something I
don't but even then it's more right he's
definitely added them he's using that
same math when he's talking about
figures for everything he's produced as
well right he has a problem he has a
problem with numbers yeah yeah but yeah
he goes he can't accept the fact that
adults think he sucks that has to be
kids sorry Ryan right he just because
you hang out with 13 to 19 year
olds like you know Bryce hall for
example I don't know how old he is now
but he was pretty young when they
started becoming
besties he says in his failure podcast
that he's not good with
numbers he does guys called him out he's
like I see now why you're a failure
because you can't get your number I
can't wait to get to that but this is
too good all of these people who
actually create the content it's it's
content by popular
oops who what the but Insurance
Specialist but you still get some of the
hold on what the [__] did specialist and
wait what happened who is this little
guy I want toand people who kind of main
the people who turned you know we are at
to manipulate the press and the
narrative I just want to keep watching
it was a viral moment which led me to
them say let's go do an event with add
that um on his site on his podcast it
turns out this guy has 7 million uh
vandalized on your
Wikipedia and then all of a sudden I got
a text from him saying the people that e
all right I'm just skipping forward Big
Time across the board and what's really
interesting is I'm a producer at heart I
make movies I just it's nice you're a
producer at a heart I mean are you a
producer in real life no because of you
he says because of me you took that away
from him but did I [__] get in the
time machine and bankrupt relativity
you're like the Soviet Union you're
rewriting history is it your fault that
we it's all my skill house yet did I
drive that car
drunk under the influence you wait to
release failure until the first guest
was a charge with saay no that wasn't me
37 days I I actually sit next to
director accused accus accus Ethan
decideded 50 podcasts on me or whatever
number he did that I'm not a producer I
just raised money he doesn't want it to
say that I produced any movies so BR I
don't care this I don't care about your
production record if anything I think
I've given it up to him like yeah he
made a lot of good movies back in the
day mhm yeah he's trying to say that he
thinks somebody is trying to say he's
not a real producer because all he did
was raise
money that's another thought that's what
a producer that's a producer what do you
think your job is that was also another
thought I had like
he that's it what what the [__] else do
you do yeah go on a Wikipedia I'm not a
producer I'm a guy who raised some money
for the studios even though I am a
producer and I'm a credited producer and
I'm a PGA producer and bro you so he's
so living in the past nobody nobody said
otherwise he he was really stuck when he
was like important and at relativity and
people respect he's stuck there he can't
get past it this is what it all comes
down to stunted
development yeah yeah all these pictures
of himself that's embarrassing
sess and I mean what year is this [__]
from
man you know mid 2000 or late 2000s I
mean dude it's time to move
on [__] I'm looking at across from me
the my academy uh plaques and my AFI
Awards and
um great you know obviously there's no
one who worked with me that wouldn't say
I'm the producer in every sense of the
word I've never said that um but they've
removed any mention of it and even
though there's hundreds of Articles Hol
reporter variety all the same sources
that say it so what I I don't even know
what he's talking about he's saying that
according to his Wikipedia article he is
not a producer however I'm looking at
his Wikipedia article right now or is
this an old one oh I'm sorry I was
looking at the it definitely says he was
a producer American film
fin um let's see if the word producer
appears occupation film producer
literally under his
photo and that's generous because that's
not your current occupation yeah former
occupation for well skill house no skill
house well we don't know that that movie
was real
yet I'll believe it when I see it then
you'll be a producer again yeah no uh on
the on here let me uh put it on
screen boom you open the page here he is
birthday occupation I'm pretty sure so
what is the problem the problem is that
I don't know that's what I'm confused
about like there was like a long list of
like his projects that that he needs
that list back I don't know what he
producer credit as executive producer
reputation as a producer executive
producer three Productions Academy
Awards here filmograph producer here it
all is producer on this when's the last
one he made uh hunter killer 2018 2018
that's way too
recent uh no 2018 cuz it was going
through all the turmoil like 2016 17
18 there's no way that movie made money
I don't know what it is but with that
name no
way hunter killer an action thriller how
come skill house isn't on there uh cuz
it does I don't know all right let's
keep going let's keep going they did is
they they they pieced together and they
took pretty much any articles they could
find that had a negative line about me
so let's say there was um a there was a
12-page Vanity Fair spread on me which
was 95% positive and listen nobody's
perfect I made mistakes and they list my
mistakes and I own my mistakes so in
there it's like you get upset when
people talk about it not at all not at
all he got a um it's not a Dy but a wet
and Reckless in 2006 and I don't know
something else I got sued ones by so and
so well it doesn't have any of the so he
goes I got a wet and Reckless and I was
sued by soand
so yada yada yada yada yada don't worry
about it there was a settlement out of
court pages of positive it just has he
got a wet n reckless in 2006 and you
know uh got suit the rest guess what bro
you did that [__] right so
yeah play maybe just don't drive drink
and drive that's where that's the
problem that's why it's on your
Wikipedia page that's your fault he's
like it doesn't mention I was in a sick
ass Ferrari when they pulled me over
right missing the important details
right so interesting enough the people
who were trying to help me were reaching
out saying we're going to do a test and
they did a test where they said we're
just going to change grammar again he's
admitting to soliciting people editing
Wikipedia he says the people that I'm
working with are doing tests trying to
change grammar um that that's against
the rules he's admitting once again he's
still doing it he's on the record now
saying he's attempting to manipulate his
own Wikipedia page a test and they did a
test where they said we're just going to
change grammar and we have a feeling
we're going to get attacked and they did
they said they went in and changed
things like the or an I think what
happened is because there was this
constant battle and because it was so
obvious that it was the person himself
trying to edit the page that they gave
it a special uh protective status mhm to
prevent him or anyone affiliated with
him from easily coming and editing it
that makes sense yeah it says right here
when you go to the talk page contentious
topics procedure applies to this page
because of all the back and forth
editing that went on so right right or
just you know year things that were
non-controversial in any way and they
literally got attacked and they got
attacked by someone named Thro and
papaki okay this is this is part's
actually really disturbing so these two
people who are their screen names on
Wikipedia since the day Ethan kind of
said everybody should go in have spent
the last two years every single day for
the first eight months it was only
editing my site every day and then it
was only add mine and Ethan site making
his and h3s you know more positive and
mine more and more negative and every
day it was you know adding more and more
and still to this day now I think they
have three or four other sites they work
on every day they doing every single day
yes I don't think that's true I'm
looking right now you say that's the
beautiful thing about uh Wikipedia is
it's all logged publicly and he's saying
so it's very easy to verify all these
things that he's
saying uh I mean I see Thro in there
sometimes let's
see thr is the man dude looks like there
was a long Gap with no edits at
all thros is the man you know he cares I
don't I don't care Al all said we were
working on four other pages I don't know
what that means I don't know
non-controversial in any way and they
literally got attacked and they got
attacked by someone named Thro and
papaki so these two people who are their
screen names on
Wikipedia since the day Ethan kind of
said everybody should go in have spent
the last two years every single day
that's for the first eight months it was
only editing my site every day and then
it was only editing mine and Ethan's
site at one hand he goes they're only
working on my one page only but then on
the other end he goes this is one of a
100 super
admins that like is deeply he might have
been saying that that was the person he
got in with or whatever that might be a
different person than Oh I thought he
was talking about Thro N I don't think
so I thought it was yeah I think he was
talking about Thro oh okay maybe I
misunderstood
H3 is you know more positive and mine
more and more negative I don't care
about my Wikipedia pise I don't look at
it he's like they were editing his page
to make it so good I don't give a [__]
bro that page has always had uh a bunch
of [__] about me and guess what it's you
know if I did controversies and it's
there that's fine that's how it works
dummy it is what it
is it was you know adding more and more
and still to this day why are you
checking my page he admits still like
monitoring my page
yeah what's up
bro you want to learn something about me
I'm trying to see if uh if thros
really edited anything on your page I
don't know curious I've I've never
checked because I just don't care no
results Thro has never touched my page
at least in the most 500 recent edits
which here I'll even go back keep going
oh no that goes all the way back to the
creation of the page no thrust has never
touched your page you've mentioned
something about your page that you don't
like and if he was a fan I feel like you
would have changed it about your
grandfather oh yeah it said that he was
my let me let me open it I haven't
looked at it in a minute youth think
client Wikipedia I did suspect that he
was defacing it though cuz like at the
same time somebody was adding like in
like in great detail all my
controversies that wasn't there before
and I'm like I don't care oh yeah no I'm
saying like thrust if or Thro if he was
uh he you guys talking about he didn't
edit yours right okay the H3 A3 P or
Productions Wikipedia page I did a uh
control F for Thro oh wait I did get
results however it's some account called
deeper Thro what which I'm pretty sure
just means that's a fan who's leaning
into the to the whole Thro M or whatever
okay wait this is I guess the H
Productions one is the one about me
are in better
detail yeah um it just says that my it
said that Leonard catsman is my grandpa
and I was like barely I don't think yeah
but then like there's controversies here
it's like I didn't even think about like
allegations against the Wall Street
Journal I was like what the
[__] uh Hussein Zada versus Klein we
love oh and that's it oh I I thought
there was more there there was a section
like he said the nword and this it's
like how is that newsworthy though right
and clearly it wasn't cuz it got
removed it's interesting how your your
current one though talks about taking
Lexa Pro and well like is that recently
added where does it say that if you go
to the your other page Ethan Klein page
at the bottom of
it Klein has Tourette syndrome and has
been vocal about how it affects his life
okay
C has also struggled with depression and
takes lone while beIN his treatment he
has said the medication changed my life
and helped me so much okay that is
that's the most interesting thing about
me I guess oh God it says Trisha PID his
sister-in-law Moses hack Moses has a
page it mentions your grand grandfather
right there I guess they added
biological grandfather maybe they okay
that did
that anyway go ahead Ryan I think they
have three or four other sites they work
on every day Thro and papaki which we
now know come from the same place um are
editing my site in a way that I cannot
correct no one at Wikipedia will respond
um and any person who is you know I call
it a good Samarian that reaches out
saying you know we know what you did and
we're trying to help you because this
isn't you bro this is insane Good
Samaritans are reaching out saying hey
this isn't you
man
if they even try to touch it they get
attacked they sit in the where they get
get threatened to lose their privileges
of editing on Wikipedia which scares
away anybody from writing anything on my
site that's positive the other part
that's that that became really scary on
that is that um
so when I tried to Lodge a complaint I
was actually locked out I cannot go on
dude he got banned cuz he was like jeez
why are you commenting on your own page
one and then they also claimed uh I
don't know based on what maybe IP or
something but they claim in the comment
section that he was running like many
sock puppet accounts and so he got
banned because you're not supposed to
edit or comment on your own page correct
me if I'm wrong but did he not threaten
legal action oh yeah he threatened to
sue them and and the mods that he named
the irony I've only heard one person in
my life ever threaten anyone on
Wikipedia I know man that's awesome
it's [__] awesome I sorry I was
asking this earlier but we got
distracted do you think he's reading
right now reading no because of his eyes
okay I don't think so I think he's just
focusing on yeah what he's saying
because I wasn't trying to do anything
shady and I was trying to be honest I
did it through my own IP address you
know I didn't block anything and I went
On's like yeah I'm an idiot I don't know
how to do that [__] that's why I got
banned guys that hi can someone help me
that my page is being destroyed by a
paid po party I know they're paid um and
that just basically got me locked out so
I I had hired piis I tracked down Thro
and papy her name's Sarah um I'll
actually give you her last name dude
this is crazy that he's saying why are
you like doxing some
random this is dangerous psycho [__]
wait we shouldn't no he does he doesn't
he doesn't identify her he goes ah I
can't remember a last name I'll have to
go get it but he never does so he
doesn't actually ever say anything that
will
[__] nuts dude yeah it is um and I'll
look it up in one second and they live
in a commune and so apparently these two
live in a commune together I want to go
what do you mean I want to go to the
Wikipedia editor commun dude there's
that Wikipedia editor commune where
they're just editing Ryan's page dude
you are getting [__] fleeced I'm
pretty like I don't listen I don't have
all the information but hearing him talk
about how he's being approached by
people who supposedly are manipulating
his life and blah blah blah what I think
is really going on is that Pi is taking
you for a ride Ryan because if assuming
this really happened because there is no
way that there is some like communist
Wikipedia editor
commune with all these people that are
obsessed with your life your Wikipedia
that is that
is actually crazy that you think that a
movie even have you seen the movie
Beautiful Mind yeah right so you
remember how he's like his roommate who
he's like spending all the time with it
ends up not being real I have a feeling
that something like that's happening
could be I I just I don't could be what
a that would be you know it's not your
fault actually sent authorities over
there um now we're having to sue them uh
he sent the authorities to a commune
what for what for editing what
authorities bro this is I mean how nuts
is this this bananas I wasn't trying to
do anything shady and I was trying to be
honest I did it through my own IP
address you know I didn't block anything
and I went on it I said guys that hi can
someone help me that my page is being
destroyed by a paid party I know they're
paid um and that just basically got me
locked out so I I had hired piis I
tracked down Thro and Pap her name is
Sarah um I'll actually give you her last
name God um and I'll look it up in one
second and they live in a commune and we
actually sent authorities over there um
now we're having to sue them uh and
they're protected in this kind of
commune like so nobody can really get to
them dude it's like the
[__] what are they holding up in
there like refusing to leave or what
what's that cult that like oh everyone
had to kill they all had guns and
shitan
I have a Waco compound where they're
editing Ryan's page I think it's
beautiful that bokei and um Thro live
together I didn't I had no idea about
that that that they were maybe they met
after they they saw each other and
they're like I saw you on the Ryan
kavana talk page on Wikipedia I love
editing my favorite thing is editing his
Wikipedia page you too they have so much
in common let's move to a compound in
Waco this man says I can't get to them
they're being protected and they live in
a Comm and we actually sent authorities
over there um now we're having to we
sent authorities over there he sent the
police who's we well he he does have
connections to the police so maybe he
actually did if it's in California he
might actually have been able to
although it didn't seem like they got
very uh deep into that
investigation if they're being protected
by a commune uh and they're protected in
this kind of commune like so nobody can
really get to them dude
dude what this is is
insane I
mean it's interesting do you think he
always as crazy or is he like losing it
um I don't know CU like this is next
level actually for like everything I
we've encountered so far from him this
is the craziest thing he's probably
always had it he's just never been like
he's never had to deal with any [__]
like this I feel like he's got nothing
left to lose like at this point his the
tril thing is not working his fight club
all the [__] he's been working on you
know he's made this podcast still not
out he's making this podcast where he's
having to edit out the people that
worked on it right and and and then he
made this movie with Bryce Hall that's
never coming out so he has nothing Chad
said pooki Bin
Laden hey what's P what is that the the
mods or the uh Wikipedia pokei they said
pooke Bin Laden I don't get it CU hiding
in compound cuz they're oh pooki Bin
Laden got it cuz he's in like a
terrorist compound got
it
funny Kev Kev hit me
up I'll double like Kanye I'll double it
send him the contract I'll dble his pay
and this F and here's the funny part is
I sue I ended up having to sue Ethan for
all the things he did wrong and I won
you did not win what are you talking
about you did not win the lawsuit
you did
not like this is at this point I
starting to
question yeah we're do we need to 5150
Ryan Kavanaugh we need to get him on
what was the thing Britney was on we
need get him conservator conservatorship
dude we got to contact his XY for the
bull or somebody to take over yeah maybe
the bull yeah he got it it to be a
complete the cuck Circle
right defamation case that you they
possible to
win yeah and you didn't win you didn't
win
the dumy this the first time I hear a
voice yeah right yeah yeah he goes is it
possible to win those yeah well you
didn't win
itation I mean so much for S versus the
New York Times apparently but I'm glad
it at least was upheld in this um uh
we're going to take one more quick break
and then come back and ads are one of my
favorite Parts watch about the uh zoomed
out implications of this because
obiously
it's problem no giv a [__] about it's
problematic she has no idea
what fourth
Branch checked it out we've
got
uh hi this is sea Morgan with an amp
consum specialist in insurance and Danny
a lot of people are worried about bomic
about the
situation how volatile everything yo is
he really on the beach yeah for real and
they're curious about fix index
so that's
one people they
have hold
on God damn it so slow free
consultations for those who
are Patriot oh they just had one fat ad
there okay love
that oh according to this post this is
good Obama probably one of the most
hated men in the country at a time and
not by general public but by
conservatives by Kavanaugh by Kavanaugh
too according to this Barack Obama faced
30 Death Threats a day stretching the US
Secret Service so I mean we Crush
that do we crush the
president on terms of death well I think
we got the Guinness World Record 20 a
second is so funny we got it so funny or
20 per minute M 20 per
minute dude you only get 30 in a day my
boy Ryan gets that in a
minute so good Banks don't need to keep
any funds on hand this means Banks all
right come on banks are going liquid
real critical in the back half of
this wait hold
on my pill.com or the number your screen
use your promo yeah let me look at the
time yeah there a highlighted one but I
wanted you to take
first uh which one he uh oh I like this
one where she Compares it to the Soviet
Union yeah that one's good too oh that
come that's coming up right after this
so hold on let me just watch that and
then I'll code to get your limited
edition 20th anniversary my pillow queen
size for $69.98 now only1 1998 that's
right get a
queen98 from all here at my
pillow Amer got I want another calling I
know Miss
missing all right buckle up
buckos so as bad as this sounds for one
person who has been through this
trajectory of Hell of uh personal you
know vilification that is publicly
available to anyone who wants to look it
up and then there's no recourse in terms
of trying to rectify it or fix it or get
the actual proper facts out there right
the zoomed out bigger problem
implication and not for nothing but this
is the story of you know stalinist
Soviet Union and how they rewrote
history it took generation to do it look
at this [__] alarm um alarming
because if there's if there's no system
of checks and
balances there's no it's Lawless you're
talking about the wild west here
Wikipedia is not the government agency
do it's well what agency do they report
to we're talking about Wikipedia editors
listen D to to Ryan kavan all they're
like Jedi like they're you know what I
mean they're Above the Law they could do
whatever there's no one that can them
it's big business I like they for big
government that regulates Wikipedia
kev's like finally someone taking this
serious system of checks and my favorite
part here system of checks in one
generation to look it up and then
there's no recourse in terms of
it or fix it or get the actual prop out
there the zoomed out bigger problem and
implication and not for nothing but this
is the story
of stalinist Soviet Union and how they
rewrote history it took one generation
to do it just like just like Stalin
Soviet Union that hit home for him he
felt that yeah he's like this is the
part Dan I was talking about earlier I
was watching this in two times speed and
just looking at Ryan he looked so unwell
yeah he doesn't look yeah Vladimir Putin
uh this part yeah this was funny he he's
turning into like Keem star where
whenever he mentions me he has to bring
out the greatest hits to try to like
prove to people that I'm a terrible
person and he's awesome this is he
go they can do this to me and this is
some YouTube blogger who just happens to
have a following that literally is a
professional troll I I I when I say
professional troll I mean he has had
numerous episodes where he's gotten on
and he said I like the words and he says
the nword and the f word he says and I
can't be cancelled watch and he said
what what okay all right team the
nword the N word f word N word f word he
says it over and over he's like I just
love how it rolls off my
tongue he said he wanted Ben Shapiro to
be the next in the guest Chambers okay
well that is missing
that is missing a lot of cont enormous
amount of the fact that I'm Israeli
Jewish have anything maybe interesting
to disclose death to the Jews death to
Israel yeah I mean if anyone's
anti-semitic it's Ben Sho play death to
the Jews death to Israel
exactly play the whole thing dude it's
way too good albar death to America
death to the Jews death to Israel
yeah it's all he does and yet he's still
platformed and of all things he's able
to control The Narrative of people so if
he's able to control The Narrative of
people and if it cost me now millions of
dollars which you'd have I don't know
how the [__] you spent millions of
dollars I guess if you're hiring armies
of pis to stalk communes maybe I don't
know I don't know you spend that much
money on
this if you have if you're bringing
together think tanks of the brightest
Wikipedia mind I guess you can spend a
lot of money yeah and to be able to get
just things removed I don't even know if
I'll be able to get the page back to
totally accurate but at least where he's
not having his paid editors um poopy and
throws not only change it every day but
and Sarah um uh get he tries again the
docker but he's too dumb him and attack
people who are just trying to create
fact on Wikipedia which is what it was
supposed to be created for imagine when
you have political power and political
money all right no this is good have an
unlimited arsenal of people to upvote as
he would say and create your own
narrative you can destroy a political
opponent you can destroy an entire party
you can rewrite history completely bro
I'm just doing like a silly comedy
show you know what I mean it's not not
that serious they were the last line of
defense as a person who studied
political science and when I was in
college the Cold War was really what we
studied it's literally The Playbook uh
you bring up Stalin is the Playbook of
Hitler and Stalin wow you're just like
Hitler and Stalin bro it's a Wikipedia
page that I don't have anything to do
with and now we're talking about
Nazis the Nazi Playbook yeah the last
time stamp at
5623 where she tells them you got to
wrap it up wrap it up yeah here it
is see
wait hold on yeah I just noticed
something interesting go back to the to
the episode mhm T oh [__] look at
his uh lower third his uh title card
Ryan Kavanaugh filmmaker
philanthropist is that supposed to he's
got an
asteris
yeah wait where where's the asteris
where's the foot no
Ryan podcast failure yeah the podcast is
not out by the way here also financier
he's is not a
producer as a producer oh my God Ryan
get out of there she's in on it one
thing he's for sure not is a filmmaker
she's a plant dude you know the you know
the other financier that comes to mind
when I hear that Jeffrey Epstein he was
a financier that's how people always
describe him well and I often heard
Harvey Weinstein refer as a Hollywood
financier they also misspelled Finance
Year too
oh my God you're right
financer
financer it's awesome it's crazy I mean
this I was watching this [__] just
flabbergasted it's nuts that he's doing
all these interviews and
stuff yall need some you guys need some
editors dude that that uh that asteris
was there on another card oh so it's
just a design Choice design poor just
forunate
placement let's put as where it make it
look like he's lying about being a
threat
philanthropist all right here's the end
of it which is good times somebody in
the chat said that's Sarah she Sarah no
that's what poke the threat was I mean
in his mind I am that level of
Mastermind genius yeah know in fact yes
that is her R actually that's me Ryan
it's Olivia that's actually Olivia I
interview we're in your walls Ryan
really I a process of which um not
factchecking is done not um wait is this
stor uh of opinion or she cuts them off
but where the rewriting of History the
rewriting of History you said it six
times yeah we are out of time so we out
of time and I think he looks so upset
got the music playing this how are you
out of time you're doing an internet
show there's no what do you mean you're
out of time look at his face dude he's
so sad
opinion I just
likeing of History the rewriting of
history is
done we are out of time we're out of
time and I thank you so much Ryan for
being with us again he just had a
flashback do like High School Middle
School shut down we got the music play
he heard the bull yeah [__] oh my God
that's funny so there's poor Ryan
kavanau he's been through
hell wow there's so many great moments I
mean like let's see we we got to go is
we're over the 4 Hour Mark yeah we are
yes okay all right and it's 5:30 so I
guess tune in on Friday for some failure
podcast I mean I I don't know what to do
he's he the Lord
provideth my my cup over filth this was
just an
appetiser the failures the main course I
think wow good wow
so
um tomorrow I'm doing the
members see you next Thursday right yeah
yeah
yeah also I don't know if we talked
about but on Tuesday we we shot
something really fun that we'll be
putting out on Friday so looking forward
to
that and uh for members I'll see you
guys tomorrow for see you next Thursday
to everyone else thank you so much for
being here and thank you to everybody
out there for your vigilance and on
Wikipedia don't even joke thank you to
the 50,000 uh hired
mods the continually uh see at home at
the commune tonight and by the way to
the 20 and let me just say this for the
record to the 20 or 30,000 of you
sending death threats to briyan on a
daily basis don't do that yeah stop it
that's not nice that's way too many
30,000 in one day I mean tone it down
send some not that much no
don't send any don't send any that was a
joke you can see how much it RS him
up he's he doesn't care about the death
stress so he just cares about Wikipedia
yeah that's true he did say that 30,000
it's like his mailbox is full of it his
email his phone it's like when Harry
Potter kept getting all those letters
exactly that's that they're all dead
threats
[__] all right we're having too much fun
here yeah uh
Ryan we can build a bridge it's not too
late we can build a bridge hey suck
these
balls not after that [__] you Ryan all
right so we'll see you guys uh on on
Friday thank you guys so much for your
support thank you to our members love
you all so very much and uh this is
Ethan and the crew signing
out